welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday life
I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a professor
of neurobiology and Ophthalmology at
Stanford School of Medicine
today my guest is Dr Noam Sobel Dr Noam
Sobel is a professor of neurobiology in
the department of brain Sciences at the
Wiseman Institute of science his
laboratory studies olfaction and
chemosensation olfaction is of course
our sense of smell chemo sensation is
our ability to respond to chemicals in
our environment today we're going to
learn some absolutely incredible facts
about how you interact with the world
and other people around you for instance
you will learn that humans can smell
things around them as well as dogs can
in fact humans are incredibly good at
sensing the chemical world around them
you also learn for instance that every
time you meet somebody you are taking
chemicals from that person either from
the chemical Cloud that surrounds them
or directly from the surface of their
body and you are actually applying it to
your own body and you are processing
information about that person's
chemicals to determine many things about
them including how stressed they are
their hormone levels things that operate
at a subconscious love level on your
brain and nervous system and the impact
your emotions your decision making and
who you choose to relate to or not to
relate to you will also learn that tears
yes the tears of others are impacting
your hormone levels in powerful ways
you will also learn that every so often
actually on a regular schedule there is
an alternation of ease through which you
can breathe through one nostril or the
other and that alternation reflects an
underlying Dynamic of your nervous
system and has a lot to do with how
alert or sleepy you happen to be
the list of things that Dr Nome sobel's
laboratory has discovered that relate to
everyday life and that are going to make
you say wow I can't believe that happens
but then go out into the real world and
actually observe that that happens in
ways that are incredibly interesting
just goes on and on in fact his
laboratory discovered that we are always
sensing our own odors that's right even
though you might not notice your own
smell you are always sensing your own
odor cloud and throughout the day you
periodically smell yourself deliberately
even though you might not realize it in
order to change your cognition and
behavior I first learned of Dr sobel's
laboratory through a rather odd
observance that observance took place
when I was a graduate student many years
ago at UC Berkeley at the time Nom Sobo
was a professor at UC Berkeley as I
mentioned before he has since moved to
the Weissman well I was walking through
the Berkeley campus and I saw people on
their hands and knees but with their
head very close to the ground and their
eyes were covered their hands were
covered their mouths were covered and
only their nose was exposed and what I
was observing was an experiment being
conducted by the Sobel laboratory in
which humans were following a scent
trail that Central was actually buried
some depth underneath the Earth and yet
they could follow that Central with a
high degree of fidelity it was from that
experiment and other experiments done in
Dr sobel's laboratory at Berkeley and at
the Wiseman involving neuroimaging and a
number of other tools and techniques
that revealed the incredible power of
human old faction and humans ability to
follow scent Trails if they need to and
that of course led to many other
important discoveries some of which I
alluded to a few moments ago but you are
going to learn about many many other
important discoveries in the realm of
olfaction in chemosensation that have
been carried out by Dr Silver's
laboratory through the course of today's
episode and by the end of today's
episode I assure you that you will never
look at or smell the world around you
the same way again before we begin I'd
like to emphasize that this podcast is
separate from my teaching and research
roles at Stanford it is however part of
my desire and effort to bring zero cost
to Consumer information about science
and science related tools to the general
public in keeping with that theme I'd
like to thank the sponsors of today's
podcast our first sponsor is Roca Rococo
makes eyeglasses and sunglasses that are
of the absolute highest quality I've
spent a lifetime working on the biology
the visual system and I can tell you
that your visual system has to contend
with an enormous number of challenges in
order for you to be able to see clearly
Roca eyeglasses and sunglasses were
designed with the biology of the visual
system in mind so no matter whether or
not you're wearing them for sport
whether or not you're wearing them for
work or for socializing you can always
see with Crystal Clarity their glasses
are extremely lightweight so most of the
time you don't even realize that you're
wearing them I wear Roca readers at
night and sometimes when I drive at
night and I wear Roca sunglasses
throughout the day except of course I do
not wear them for my morning sunlight
viewing if you'd like to try Roca
eyeglasses or sunglasses go to Roka
that's roka.com and enter the code
huberman to save 20 off your first order
again that's roka.com and enter the code
huberman at checkout today's episode is
also brought To Us by thesis thesis
makes custom nootropics and nootropics
is a word that I do not like because it
means smart drugs as a neurobiologist I
can tell you that there is no neural
circuit in your brain for being smart
there are neural circuits for Focus
there are neural circuits for memory
there are neural circuits for creativity
and there are neural circuits for task
switching thesis understands that
there's a diversity of neural circuits
that support different brain body States
and therefore design nootropics that are
customized to achieve specific brain
body States if you go to the thesis
website and take a brief quiz they will
design a nootropic starter kit some of
those nootropics that they'll send you
are designed to enhance your focus
others for clarity others for creativity
and so on to get your own personalized
nootropic starter kit you can go to take
thesis.com huberman and take a
three-minute quiz and thesis will send
you four different formulas to try on
your first month that's takethesis.com
huberman and use the code Huber minute
checkout to get 10 percent off your
first order today's episode is also
brought To Us by Helix sleep Helix sleep
makes customized mattresses and pillows
that allow you to get the best possible
night's sleep so if you go to the Helix
website you can take a very brief quiz
it only takes about two minutes and
answer questions such as do you tend to
sleep on your back or your side or your
stomach do you tend to run hot or cold
throughout the night maybe you don't
know the answers to those questions but
they'll match you to a mattress that's
ideal for your sleep needs for me that
was the dusk dusk mattress which is not
too firm and not too soft and I've been
sleeping on it for more than two years
and it's the best sleep that I've ever
had if you'd like to try a helix
mattress go to helixsleep.com huberman
take that two minute quiz and they'll
match you to a customized mattress and
you'll get up to 350 off any mattress
order and two free pillows again if
you're interested you can go to
helixsleep.com huberman for up to 350
off and two free pillows and now for my
discussion with Dr Noam Sobel Dr Sobel
gnome welcome thank you must say I am
extremely excited for this come
conversation I've been a huge fan of
your work for more than a decade or two
uh yes kind of frightening yeah but yeah
we overlapped at UC Berkeley some time
ago although we did not meet and we
lived in the same apartment and we just
learned that the amazing apartment
that you moved out of was the apartment
that my girlfriend and I at the time
moved into in 2006 I believe so uh
we've shared quite a few things
um and today I would love for you to
share with us
um All About The Amazing landscape of
chemo sensation in particular olfaction
or sense of smell and some related
perceptual abilities or subconscious
abilities including pheromones Etc
to get everybody on the same page I'd
like to just start off by asking
what are the major components of our
ability to smell
obviously or I like to think it involves
the nose at some level it does to what
extent is that mixed in with other
senses like taste and
perhaps more importantly
what about the chemicals that we are
sensing through this thing and for those
of you listening um and not watching I'm
tapping my nose that we are not aware of
you know that the chemicals that are
that we're inhaling and
um making sense of without our awareness
if you could just um give us the top
Contour or even deep Contour if you like
of the uh the parts list and the various
roles they play so you you've asked a
lot of questions at once
um you know I'll start with a little
comment on the way you you said smelling
through our nose which we indeed do but
we also smell through our mouth actually
there's a process referred to as
retronasal olfaction where
um odorants come up through our the back
of our throat and
out of our nose the reverse way and we
smell things that way as well and in
fact a big part of the contribution of
olfaction to food and taste comes from
that from retro nasal off action but uh
uh primary olfaction is referred to as
orthonasal faction that is through our
news we Sniff and sniffing is a big
thing well I have a sense we might talk
about that a lot today in all sorts of
contexts so we sniff in through our nose
and to answer your general question of
the organization of the system
um so molecules Airborne molecules
travel up our nose a distance in the
human of about six or seven centimeters
to about here where they interact with I
will use the word sheet of receptors but
she is a bit misleading here it's not a
sheet it's very convoluted
we have about seven million such
receptors uh lining a structure known as
the olfactory epithelium this is the
sensory surface of the olfactory system
the olfactory epithelium again about
probably about six or seven million
receptors in the human in the human
probably of about
350 different kinds so that's amazing
that means a meaningful percentage of
your genome is devoted just to this just
to the kinds of olfactory receptor
subtypes you have in your nose by the
way I can share an amusing story I would
imagine amusing stories are good for
podcasts
so that number of six or seven million
receptors
is probably not very well grounded it's
hard to count but it's reasonably
grounded and there was this thing
roaming around in the literature about
Bloodhounds having billion receptors in
their nose which is why they're so
amazing and this number was you know it
sort of propagated through the
literature and and our lab has written
over the years a few review chapters and
and we were repeatedly writing the
olfaction chapter for a very large one
of these large textbooks the gazanaga
handbook of cognitive Neuroscience I
think it's called
um
and and we had that in there as well
somewhere and and one time when we're
renewing the chapter for a new version
of the book I told the graduate student
who was leading that at the time she's
now a professor at Tel Aviv University I
told her check that check that reference
out where in the world did that come
from and we started going back and back
and back and it turns out it comes from
a textbook
an Australian textbook
and we found the author of The Textbook
and and we wrote her and I said look
there's this thing in in the literature
of a billion receptors in in the
Bloodhound where did that come from
and and surprisingly she answered me and
you know I was hoping to get a reference
right but it was a reference and and
this is where it really becomes funny
for us because she said I I was once um
at a lecture of uh an all-faction
geneticists geneticist by the name of
Duron Lancet and he said that in the
lecture now this is really funny because
she's in Australia this is all over the
world this number and I'm writing her
from Israel and Doran lancid is in the
building next to me okay he's in
Weitzman Institute genetics I mean he
used to be he's retired now uh and and
he he had meaningful contributions in
the history of wolf action
um so I picked up the internal phone and
and I said hey Duron you know did you
say that there's a billion receptors in
the Bloodhound knows and he said what's
a bloodhound
so this is totally made up right it
totally made up and it propagated I mean
you can you can probably go into Google
and type like a billion receptors in the
blood town and you'll get a lot of hits
but there was absolutely no evidence for
that amazing and not just amazing in
light of what it it tells us about
olfaction and Bloodhounds or otherwise
but amazing because it sheds light on
just how much of what is in textbooks
scientific and medical is absolutely
wrong things things propagate and and
you know you set yourself in right so we
fixed that in that version of right and
and so to finish the line so that so
odorants interact with these receptors
um here in our epithelium where they
undergo what is referred to as
transduction that is the odorance our
Dock of the receptor and turn into a
neural signal or
enforce the receptor to respond in a
neural signal and this neural signal in
fact action potential is not gradient
potentials of any kind uh propagates uh
via the olfactory nerve now this is a
nerve that goes from our epithelium
right here behind the forehead no it's
well yeah yeah here uh through uh the
thinnest part of our skull an area
referred to as the cribriform plate
which is perforated it has a lot of
holes the nerve goes through those holes
and synapses at the first Target in the
brain uh which is the olfactory bulb
and humans
that forms an interesting
uh point of sensitivity
um because a lot of people lose their
sense of smell due to trauma uh because
of that structure yeah a head hit type
trauma well yes although uh you denoted
hitting on the front of the head which
is where all this real estate is but
actually uh the more common cause for
losing your sense of smell for trauma is
the back of the head because of what's
referred to as a contra coup injury so
as your listener is probably no our
brain is floating in liquid in CSF and
cerebrospinal fluid inside our skull and
when we get hit in the back of the head
the brain has this forward and backward
movement in the liquid in in the skull
it sort of crashes it can crash against
the front of the skull which is why you
also have in a contract Winery you also
often have frontal damage but what
happens is that this generates a
shearing motion on the crib form plate
and the olfactory nerve is severed and
if it's completely severed it's it's
lost forever because my understanding is
that the olfactory Sensory neurons can
are among the few central nervous system
neurons in adult humans that can
regenerate so or replenish themselves
right so so I'll I'll again there are a
few questions yeah that's okay so first
of all we will spin many plates
simultaneously if it's completely
severed completely then yes you're lost
forever yeah if it's completely savored
because even if you'll have regeneration
at the basal cell level at epithelium
they won't manage to find their way back
uh to the bulb if if you have partial or
something left or something shows up in
a short while after the injury then you
have a good chance of recovery because
they grow along the trajectory of the
other axons or pioneering the way for
them assumingly yeah interesting and so
so basically and and basically the time
frame and you know it's funny I get a
lot of emails on this although I'm not a
medical doctor but but I get a lot of
emails from people who have lost their
sense of smell because it's very
distressing and now more people know
this because of kovid that it's very
distressing
and and basically the rule of thumb is
that if you don't get it back within a
year to a year and a half you'll never
uh get it back my understanding of the
statistics on olfactory loss in covid
and and other viral type infections is
that
um first of all I had I experienced that
when I got covered including total and
awesome for one day and not total it was
just there was a remnant of an ability
to to smell or set or perceive the smell
of a lemon and I was huffing as hard as
I possibly could I actually uh there's
an over-the-counter remedy and this is
not uh pseudoscience because there's a
number of papers published about this on
PubMed the alpha lipoic acid can
accelerate the recovery of of smell yeah
and and so that's something that it
worked successfully for me I'm not
saying that that's the only or I don't
know if it works successfully for you or
if you would have recovered anyway I
mean you didn't do a control that I was
not willing to do the control experiment
uh exactly yeah let me say two things on
this front first the date on the alpha
lipoic acid is
[Music]
one word about the smelling the lemon
and this is uh I'll take that
opportunity to to share more information
when we smell things
it's the result of more sensory
subsystems than the olfactory system
alone
so you have several chemosensory
sensitive nerves in your nose
a primary one beyond the olfactory nerve
is the trigeminal nerve the fifth
cranial nerve so the trigeminal nerve
has sensory endings in your nose and
your throat and in your eye it has three
branches that's why an onion has smell
and burns your eyes and burns in your
throat itself trigeminal yeah the
tearing of cutting an onion is a
trigeminal reflex amazing we talked
about trigeminal in the context of
headache during a headache episode it's
a trigeminal reflex so the lemon you are
smelling may have been a trigeminal
sensation so smelling the lemon with my
eyes is what you're saying well no with
your nose but with your trigeminal
receptors and not your olfactory
receptors
um so in within you know all faction
researcher jargon uh there's what we
refer to as pure olfactants these are
orders that will stimulate your
olfactory nerve alone they won't
influence your trigeminal nerve at all
and an example just to get a sense of
what that might be would be uh the
coffee right here is a purolfactant of
vanilla is a known plural factant these
things have no trigeminal activation
um but as long as we're on this topic
and we'll weave back and forth but I'm
glad we are on this topic because a
tremendous number of people wrote to me
during the pandemic and continue to
about olfactory uh loss
um
is the I I've heard of this olfactory
training where whereby if you have a
partial or even a complete loss of of
primary olfaction right that um one is
encouraged to smell a number of
different smells I I grew up studying
activity dependent wiring of the nervous
system it makes total sense to me why
keeping neurons active keeps them alive
so this is not fired together wired
together type thing by the way that's a
quote from Carla Schatz not Donald head
folks or me
um but this is about keeping neurons
electrically active in this case
olfactory neurons in order to maintain
their connections because otherwise they
will die
of action is a definite use it or lose
it system and so that makes total sense
and indeed there's very strong evidence
for success of of the training programs
more than the alpha lipoic acid right
and and so that's a real thing and and
what's cool about that is that you don't
need to go out and buy expensive things
although you can of course there are
people who are capitalizing on this
commercially already but you can just
take things from your refrigerator or
your or your you know makeup cabinet or
whatever and smell them
you know attentionally and constantly
and sniff them and and that exposure
will help you recover uh there's good
data on that by now you made that uh
point in passing about regeneration in
the olfactory system and neither one of
one of the cool things so in all faction
you can you can study many things
through all faction indeed one of them
is is an is neuro regeneration uh
because the olfactory neurons are really
the only neurons that do that
systematically in the adult mammalian
brain and whether the human olfactory
system shows the same level of
regeneration as it does in in uh in
other mammals is and was somewhat
questionable and I'm just bringing that
up to share a really cool study that was
published in neuron I think somewhere
around 2014
um where to address this question I just
really like the idea of doing that what
they what the authors did
um
was look at in in postmortem they looked
at levels of c14 in in
adults were exposed to Atomic Bomb
experiments right so you have you can
actually look at these at these neurons
and and time them based on exposure to
radiation
um and that paper suggested that that
there's not as much turnover in the
human olfactory bulb as there is in
other mammals
uh
other lines of data suggest otherwise so
this is kind of a debated question as to
what extent degeneration you have in in
the human olfactory system as opposed to
other uh mammals but but that was just a
really cool paper I think of of doing
that fascinating no I I
should I finish the the path just so we
have to so so we said so so information
then synapses at the olfactory bulb from
from uh uh the olfactory epithelium
and
the pattern of that synapsing follows
what's referred to as the most extreme
case of convergence in the mammalian
nervous system more specifically what
happens is that all the receptors of a
given subtype and remember in humans we
said we have about 350 in the mouse we
have about a thousand two hundred
probably
so all the receptors of one subtype
converge to one location in the bulb and
this location is referred to as a
glomerulus or an employee and and that
may be a slight oversimplification it's
in fact two glomeruli there is a mirror
sort of a mirror cut line and so all the
receptors of one subtype will converge
to two mirror glomeruli on the olfactory
bulb so you end up having uh two
glomeruli that reflect that one receptor
subtype
and so if and this is as far as I'm
giving you now the textbook view of of
how the system works but then I can I'll
happily share with you things that
pose a problem for the textbook view of
how things work but the textbook view of
how things work is that every such
receptor subtype is responsive to a
small subset of different molecular
shapes what sometimes referred to as
autotopes the molecular aspects of
deodorant so each receptor is is
responsive to a different subset of
odotopes let's say 10 and each ototope
will activate a different subset of
receptors so potentially you have this
insane common and torics of this
potentially 350 dimensional space in the
human potentially
but then because of this convergence you
end up having on the bulb in a way a map
reflecting or receptor identity so so
let's say this coffee activates
receptors of type 1 3 and 7 so the
glomeruli of receptors one three and
seven will light up quote unquote when I
smell the coffee and if you could take a
snapshot of that theoretically you would
have the map of of coffee and and so on
and so forth this this is sort of the
textbook view of how the system works
and and then information goes from the
bulb
to several Targets in the brain I mean
what is referred to as primary olfactory
cortex is piriform cortex and then the
Rhino cortex this is on the ventral
surface of the brain the lower portion
of our temporal lobe
um and information goes there directly
but it also goes directly to the
amygdala it probably goes directly to
the hypothalamus it may go directly to
the cerebellum uh it goes all over the
brain so so information projects widely
from there and as far as people
understand
the map that may exist on the bulb
doesn't exist in the rest of the brain
and the understanding of of how coding
occurs in the rest of the brain is is
murky commonly one here is that the
memories that we have of odors are
somehow more robust
um than the memories of other perceptual
events in our life I I don't know if
this is true or not but um people will
say for instance I can still remember
the smell of my grandmother's hands or
the smell of cookies in her kitchen
at a minimum it points to the fact that
smell and memory are closely linked and
you just mentioned a direct
um you know multi-station but
nonetheless somewhat Direct
path from the nostrils to the
hippocampus one of the primary encoding
centers away yeah which is which is a
remarkably short pathway considering
that for instance uh just by example
because some of our listeners won't be
familiar with this but some will that
sound waves that uh you know are
transduced into neural signals at the
level of the inner ear go through many
stations before they arrive at the
location in the brain where we make
sense of those sound waves as voices or
music Etc whereas olfaction is more of a
direct route
um to the to the memory centers
um is there any uh gesso story or real
uh objective truth to the idea that
olfactory memories are formed more
easily or maintained longer or more
robustly than other sorts of memories so
so yes but first I I should I should say
that I'm not
an authority in all Factory memory it's
sort of it all have to remember is a
huge field of research and somehow our
lab has never really
um
gone much into that although again the
same student I happened to talk about
before I Sharon who's again now A
Faculty at Tel Aviv uh
um ran a study a paper we I think we
published in current biology biology
called the privilege representation of
early olfacturers associations basically
there's something about the first time
you experience a smell
that generates a particularly robust
representation
more than other sensory stimuli and and
that's what chain fact compared so
there's something about the first
exposure to a smell
um in terms of the brain encoding that
that etches it into our uh being
and and this is an effect that has you
know it has Echoes of course in
literature I mean you know the the
biggest cliche in this is to bring up
the priest effect right so the priest
effect is when he ate the Madeleine and
it immediately the taste and smell
immediately reminded him uh of of an
event in his childhood where where uh
where the same Madeleine uh appeared uh
um but but so that's something very real
there there's a lot of research on it uh
not coming from our work so I'm not an
authority but it does sound like there's
something special about olfaction
um and that doesn't mean that there
isn't something special about Vision or
audition each one has its own uh unique
uh I'm the last argue that there's
something special about actions my
students make fun of me because
they saying there's some truth to that
that I try to explain everything through
the olfactory system I mean for me
everything is olfactory so so yes
through the lens of the nose I'd like to
take a quick break and acknowledge one
of our sponsors athletic greens athletic
greens now called ag1 is a vitamin
mineral probiotic drink that covers all
of your foundational nutritional needs
I've been taking athletic green since
2012 so I'm delighted that they're
sponsoring the podcast the reason I
started taking athletic greens and the
reason I still take athletic greens once
are usually twice a day is that it gets
to be the probiotics that I need for gut
health our gut is very important it's
populated by gut microbiota that
communicate with the brain the immune
system and basically all the biological
systems of our body to strongly impact
our immediate and long-term health
and those probiotics and athletic greens
are optimal and vital for microbiotic
health in addition athletic greens
contains a number of adaptogens vitamins
and minerals that make sure that all of
my foundational nutritional needs are
met and it tastes great if you'd like to
try athletic greens you can go to
athleticgreens.com huberman and they'll
give you five free travel packs that
make it really easy to mix up athletic
greens while you're on the road in the
car on the plane Etc and they'll give
you a year's supply of vitamin d3k2
again that's athleticgreens.com huberman
to get the five free travel packs and
the year supply of vitamin D3 K2 when I
was at Berkeley
I was walking across campus one day and
I saw
I think students but I saw people on
their hands and knees with goggles on
gloves on and
um I think their mouths were covered too
everything was covered was covered and
they were walking well they were
crawling along the ground
um and I thought this was peculiar but
then again it's UC Berkeley and the joke
is if it to get noticed on the UC
Berkeley campus you have to be naked and
on fire right one or the other would not
be sufficient please don't run this
experience that kind of place
um yeah but nonetheless a paper came out
a few years later
describing the results of what turned
out to be your experiment that your
laboratory was running which was having
people follow an odor trail with their
nose and
um and my understanding is that people
can improve their ability to track sense
quite robustly especially if
we deprive them of vision and somatic
Sensation that is touched in some other
um Sensations maybe you could just tell
us a little bit about that study and um
and for I think in our audience I'm
suspecting that many people have a Keen
Keen sense of smell very I have a family
member who just like detect any negative
you know putrid odor in the environment
but also good odors
um exquisitely well and I I have other
family members who sense of smell is
quite poor
um
I'd love for
all of those people to learn a bit about
what is possible in terms of training up
or improving our ability to smell and
perhaps in the context of that study if
you will yeah so so first before even
talking about improving just
off the bat humans have a remarkable
sense of smell and this is something
again in our lab we already said we know
yeah we know this this is old news but
but to people who who come from
different worlds we have to reiterate
this sometimes when I give you know
public lectures to to non-all-faction
audiences I reiterate this
humans have an utterly remarkable sense
of smell to put that a bit into sort of
you know things that you could that are
tangible so so for example
um mercaptans which are added to cooking
gas so that we smell it because
otherwise it wouldn't have a smell so
that the smell of gas is not the smell
of gas of propane it's an additive
yeah it's more Captain the sulfur like
smell so so uh our detection threshold
that is the level at which we can detect
it is 0.2 parts per billion
okay there's no machine that can really
do that that effectively no gas
chromatograph nothing now to give you
another sense of of making this again
really tangible we're working with an
odorant in our lab called estro tetra
enol
that our participants can detect when we
have it mixed at 10 to the negative 12
molar in the liquid phase to give you a
real sense of that we did the math if
you would take two olympic size swimming
pools and you would pipe it 1ml one drop
into one pool versus the other you could
smell the difference between the pools
incredible that's the detection
threshold that you have with your nose
people have an utterly amazing nose Okay
so so that's just in terms of its
detection abilities which are are just
you know remarkable really up there in
the mammalian World we're not
a bad mammal at all faction
um
and and
beyond that we can we can improve okay
and and the example you're talking about
actually started off
uh is a lab bet okay we were having a
lab picnic so I guess I should hear fill
in because I I'm your guest from The
Weisman Institute of Science in Israel
but before going back to my home in
Israel I was a uh um faculty at UC
Berkeley and the Helen Wells
Neuroscience Institute and this study
was done during that time and we were on
a lab picnic and we were having indeed
one of these sort of lab discussions
arguments on what humans can and can't
do with their sense of smell and and I
said that humans could truly even track
odor like a dog and people there said no
way and we ran this quick experiment uh
which I have video of but I don't think
we'll show it here uh but I actually
have original the picnic video we have
it
and uh a graduate student by the name of
Christina zellano a brilliant graduate
student at that time who's now she's now
a professor at Northwestern
and she's really leading the field of
all faction Imaging today but she was
the volunteer and we dragged a chocolate
bar across the grass and blindfolded her
and
checked if she could track the track we
made with the chocolate which he did
very effectively right and as far as
Placer at the starting point of the line
or I think we did I don't exactly
remember what we did on that sort of
picnic uh tryout but you know I assume
she never practiced that in her life
before right and yet you know she she
did it really really well and
and then this went on as a lot better in
a way that that I I said to my my
students okay we we have to make this
into an experiment put in an
experimental setting and and and
quantify what's going on
uh
and they all said that it would be
uninteresting that was the BET and and I
told them it would be in nature which is
a bit I won in this case nature of
course being one of the the three Apex
journals so it was it was Nature
Neuroscience to prepare but but uh so so
then we we turned it into an experiment
and and what the experiment was is that
we brought in participants naive
participants not not graduate students
from our lab uh completely deprived them
of any other sensory input so we blocked
their eyes we block their ears we
blocked everything we blocked they were
wearing heavy gloves uh you know they
they couldn't sense anything
and we generated a a consistent order
path in the grass which is what you saw
we did that by burying twine under the
grass and odor impregnated twine so that
way we could generate a consistent uh
odor Trail every time was it and at the
base of the grass or in the dirt it was
buried it was buried under the grass
really yeah
yeah wow and I did not know that it was
buried under the grass
and we conducted aerial photography and
um participants also had this sensor
pack that they were wearing where we
measured nasal airflow in each nostril
in real time
and uh they all we also used something
called rtk GPS which is a way to lay uh
radio frequency grid over the GPS grid
so that you have millimeter resolution
in space basically it's used by
surveyors mostly
um so that we could track Behavior and
we found a few things doing this one is
that people could just do this right off
the bat
um the second thing we found that is
when we train them up
then within uh average of four days uh
the rate limiting factor became the
speed at which they could crawl
so as fast as you could crawl you could
send track of course you can't crawl as
fast as the dog can run but you as fast
as you can crawl you can send track
and then to sort of add what made it
really interesting from from a systems
neuroscience perspective
is
that we asked where they're having two
nostrils uh contributes to this
so we built we constructed a nasal
prosthesis if you will
uh that had two versions one is that it
combined both nostrils into one big
nostril
centered and the other is that it
maintained two separated uh nostrils and
we compared performance under these two
conditions and people perform better uh
with two nostrils over one centralized
nostril although the flu remain the same
so you're taking advantage of the
information uh that comes from your two
separate totally separate nostrils by
the way the system I described before of
your epithelium and bulb and and
connection to Cortex
um you have two of those right it's
completely unilateral well almost
completely unilateral system there's
some
very small exceptions to that but but so
a representation on both sides of the
brain much in the same way we have two
eyes we're not a cyclops we can gain
depth perception information we can
perceive motion better as a consequence
and a number of depth especially
stereopsis and we can locate sound
because of the difference between our
ears and how head blocks them between
and amazing another question about the
the mechanics and strategies that you
observed because I think there's
information about the system the brain
as a consequence
um were you in a position to measure
sniffing frequency and the specific
question I have is were people doing
something along the lines of a
quick sniffing or a like a you know a
long um withdrawal in so inhale you know
we didn't so yes we were measuring
sniffing and recording it and and we
have all the data
um
there was nothing
um very remarkable in that data in that
study although it may reflect that we
didn't analyze it carefully enough as
well I mean it didn't it was it it
wasn't a major component of our analysis
although we did look at it uh to some
extent again you're asking me about a
paper from quite a few years ago so I
may be forgetting parts of it as well
um but I'm sure if it was a major
component of it it would have risen it
definitely wasn't a major finding of the
sniffing behavior
um in the paper although again we you
know sniffing behavior is a huge portion
of our our life in lab uh
and and it's it's taking us to to places
and and it's re-emerging now in our work
we're doing tons of sniffing work
um you know I can share with you
something
that that I think will interest your
your uh listeners and viewers as well
and and and
we think is is really uh one of the most
overlooked things
in in neuroscience
I invite you to do the following
experiment so occlude one nostal by
pressing on it from the side and sniff
in and then include the other and sniff
in do you sense a difference in flow yes
okay do you know why that is no and it
was the next question on my list so
don't feel badly about not knowing why
that is
um most people don't
uh but that is a reflection of something
referred to as the nasal cycle
so in fact if you were to do that
repeatedly you would find that your high
flow nostril and low flow nostril
alternate every two and a half hours on
average in an absolute way or is it kind
of like a sine wave like gradual shift
to the one and then gradual shift back
it can vary it can vary and we don't yet
know the rules uh all the rules but but
you have this constant shift from side
to side the shift becomes incredibly
pronounced in sleep so we can measure
the power of the difference and in sleep
you have this phase shift of power you
have a huge like one closes and one
opens totally
and
it turns out that this is linked to uh
balance in the autonomic nervous system
so as you and your listeners know we
have an autonomics nervous system that
has a sympathetic and parasympathetic
component to it and and they're in
balance or imbalance in many diseases
for example and this interplay between
the uh Auto between the the sympathetic
and parasympathetic nervous system
drives the switch
from left to right nostril just to
remind people um sympathetic nervous
system has nothing to do with sympathy
um has everything to do with generating
patterns of alertness it's sometimes
called the fight or flight system but
any pattern of arousal positive or
negative and then it's balanced in a
coordinated way or at least in parallel
with the parasympathetic nervous system
which is sometimes called the rest and
digest system but as a associated with
all sorts of things the sexual arousal
response and a number of other aspects
of our physiology so think of it like a
seesaw of alertness and calm yeah
perfect so now imagine right imagine
imagine you would walk around living
your life right half of the time with
one eye closed like this and the other
half with one eye closed like this and
you have this eye cycle all right and
that was linked to autonomic arousal I
assure you you would go to PubMed there
would be five million papers on the eye
cycle right and the eye cycle in every
disease you can name and what it denotes
and what it tells us and what we can do
with it
you have exactly this marker you're
walking around with a marker on balance
in your autonomic nervous system and we
do nothing with it so we're in fact now
doing a lot with it okay so we built we
built a wearable device
that is pasted to your body and measures
airflow in each and nostrils separately
and logs it for 24 hours
and we're collecting these 24-hour
recordings we're calling it the nasal
halter
so we measure with the nasal halter
and and we're finding it as a disease
marker
um I can I can give you a nasal halter
measurement as an adult and I can say
this is work by team nasaroka graduates
in our lab now I can so we can tell the
difference between ADHD and non-adhd
adults
and we can tell just from the recording
we can tell if the adults are in ritalin
or not
so I can I can measure your nasal
airflow and say if you are or are not
with ADHD and if you are or not on
Ritalin incredible I have a couple of
questions about this
is it the case that airflow through one
nostril is reflective of a sympathetic
nervous system dominance versus
parasympathetic
um or is it simply the case that this
alternating Left Right nostril
periodicity
um which you said I think is on the
order of about every two hours two and a
half two and a half it switches to uh
maximal on one side versus the other
is that simply reflective of an overall
balancing let's maybe is it the hinge in
the Seesaw or is it the tilt of the
Seesaw so I don't have a good answer I
don't have a good answer I mean you know
I could give you sort of a you know I
could say that to some extent uh uh
right nostril more open
um is more sympathetic and the left
nostril more open is more
parasympathetic but that that wouldn't
be very correct I mean you know I'm sure
that it's you know the yogis are going
to be all over this so right because I
get this my lab does do some stuff on on
breathing and the the yogis are always
saying okay you know because there's
this thing I don't do yoga anymore but
not for anybody but um where they'll
have you breathe through one nostril or
the other and I've I've probably even
asked this question on social media
I'm gonna become Public Enemy Number One
of the yogis right now so listen we so
we we they'll come at you with um yoga
mats which are not very dangerous we
really so since we're so interested in
this mechanism one of the things we'd
really like to know how to do is is to
gain control of it somehow and there's
this world out there of yoga who claims
to have control over this
so we said okay let's bring like really
serious yoga practitioners and see if
they can shift their nasal cycle from
left to right but by Will alone right
not by manipulating themselves somehow
and and if yes you know we'll learn from
them how they do this and then we might
you know use this to to cure ADHD or or
whatnot right so
so we posted like on all the lists of
like the yoga teachers and had this
parade of yoga teachers walking into our
lab this was one of the strangers a lot
of Sandalwood odors and bare feet
white white uh clothing and and so on
and and so we we study I actually know
we studied 14 yoga teachers
all 14 uh by you know by the conditions
of enlistment for this uh came in saying
that they they can control shifting from
left to right uh nostril without
plugging a nostril yeah by the power of
thought come on
um and you know how many of 14 succeeded
zero including including one you know
the most extreme one was we had this guy
who who you know and we're recording and
we know how to record this really well
right and and he's sitting there saying
yeah I'm switching now and I'm it's
switching and you know you're looking at
the Monitor and no it's not switching
and and so no no yoga teacher that we
found uh could uh willfully switch uh
between left and right nostril flow and
yet they're they are convinced that they
are and I have to imagine they're not
trying to you know there's no incentive
for them to lie right yeah no I I it
even the opposite I mean you know this
puts them in an awkward position once
yeah I don't know what the deal is but
but none of them can do it
um given that the alternating flow
through one or the other nostrils
reflective of the autonomic nervous
system has this two and a half hour
periodicity
if I suddenly enter a bout of stress for
instance does it switch because that's
reflective of the autonomous nervous
system and the reason I'm asking this
question is not because I think that's
necessarily important as it relates to
stress but I'm trying to understand the
direction of causality in other words is
the unilateral smelling through or
unilateral nostril smelling periodicity
they've been we named it something I
could think of the wrong thing I'm sure
is that driving the shift in the
autonomic nervous system or is it merely
reflective of the shift so you've you've
very concisely now worded aim two of a
grant that was probably just rejected
but but basically we're trying to answer
exactly uh that question and we're
currently running experiments on that
line so so we have one experiment where
uh uh we're looking
um so we're exposing participants to
pain uh we're using a cold water hand
exposure it's a really cool Paradigm
because it it there's huge individual
differences we just started this we
built the setup just now
and you have a lot of meat to work with
there because there's a lot of
individual differences here it's capped
in three minutes so be for safety
reasons because you have you have
participants putting their hand in in
two degrees Celsius water
but there'll be participants who will
pull it out at like 10 seconds 9 seconds
and then you'll have you'll have three
minutes as well so there's lots of lots
of uh and and already in so now I'm
sharing pilot data with you so you know
to to this might you know when it when
this ends up being published it might be
the opposite but so far it seems that
that uh the exposure to Coal generates a
shift in the nasal and nasal balance so
autonomic arousal can drive the shift
potentially
um earlier you were describing the
architecture of these um smelling
systems and you mentioned these
glomeruli where the olfactory receptors
converge right in the bulb and then
later you mentioned that the system is
unilateral but with a mirror
representation on both sides of the
brain so for those who don't think in
terms of neuroanatomy on what no one was
describing is the fact that of course
there are two nostrils and then a bunch
of receptors they converge in these
glomerular but you have a mirror
representation of that on both sides of
the brain and that most of that
information is kept on one side of the
brain or the other there isn't a lot of
extensive intermixing at the first order
of process so the question I have is
whether or not you believe I'm not
asking for data first I just want to
know what you believe that this
alternating nostril airflow phenomenon
has anything to do with preferential
processing of olfactory information in
terms of right brain left brain with the
caveat that anytime we hear right brain
left brain
um we've covered this in a previous
episode most of what people hear out
there about right brain left brain
emotionality logical stuff is completely
wrong completely wrong doesn't exist is
a total fabrication
um and we'd like to abolish that myth
but with that aside or set aside rather
what are your thoughts on why the
information would switch from one side
of the brain to the other at all yeah I
don't think I don't think
that that the nasal cycle is an
olfaction story
um so so I I don't think that
um
that this was shaped by the olfactory
system nor do I think this has major
impact on olfaction
I think the nasal cycle story is a
different story about brain function
um so so you know we have we have this
sort of
pet Theory where calling now the the
sniffing brain approach
where
where basically
we think that that nasal inhalation
is timing and driving a lot of aspects
and patterns of of neural activity and
cognitive processing and and this theory
is is all faction inspired in its
beginning that is I mean if you think of
the mammalian brain right it's
which which
evolved from all faction it's sitting
there and an in all faction because
olfaction depends on sniffing you have
this situation where you have a you have
a sniff you have information
and then flat nothing right and then you
have information and then nothing so
information processing is is one-to-one
linked to nasal inhalation
and and we think that that
this property evolved
to to be meaningful in brain processing
in general not only of olfactory
information but of any type of
information because the brain evolved in
this way in this way that it processes
information on inhalation onset
so
a study led by offer Peril from our our
lab uh two three years ago
um we looked at something completely not
all Factory we looked at visual spatial
processing and we compared visual
spatial processing on inhalation versus
exhalation
and the brain does this completely
different on inhalation versus
exhalation you're in that particular
task people performed significantly
better on inhalation versus exhalation
what was the task was in an olfactory no
no it's a visual spatial task so this is
a task where uh the the specifics of the
tasks were
um that you see a shape and you have to
determine if it's a shape that can or
cannot exist in the real world so some
of them were these like Usher shapes
like you know where where one facet
doesn't reach the other facet The
Impossible figures yeah yeah but but but
uh structural shapes not not and and so
so a pure visual spatial task we
intentionally went for a task that is
not
considered a ventral temporal task in
olfactory cortex task in any way
and and people performed much better on
inhalation versus exhalation and doing
this task was there a both nostrils
occluded
um version where people were forced to
mouth breathe yes
and in this particular task they also
did better on mouth inhalation versus
mouth exhalation
but the difference wasn't as pronounced
as it was with nasal inhalation versus
exhalation so I'm a big proponent of
nasal not mouth breathing whenever
possible for
um many health related Reasons I'm a big
fan of the book Jaws a hidden epidemic
uh written by colleagues of mine at
Stanford familiar with it yeah and this
idea that uh people who mouth breathe
experience more colds more infections of
various kinds it's not good
aesthetically or for the dentist
dentature I never know the teeth the
gums and stuff sorry my uh my dentist is
going to come after me
um need to go to the dentist anyway the
um that nose breathing is great for your
health relative to mouth so I think it's
also good for your cognition not only
for your your dental health uh I think
that that news breathing shapes
cognition and and there other labs who
are finding the same uh again uh
Christina zellano is doing work on this
line she she had major contributions
here and and yuan lundstrom is doing
work on this line there's lots of
studies suggesting that
um nasal inhalation is timing cognitive
processing and modulating it
incredible um perhaps not surprising
given what you've taught us about the
olfactory system I mean that these two
holes in the front of our face these
nostrils I mean are
a pathway to the brain right I I love to
tell people because I work on the visual
system in my lab that you know your eyes
are two pieces of brain extruded from
the cranial Vault right which they are
the retina is any anyhow and um and then
you never look at anyone the same way
again it's okay but the the olfactory
Sensory neurons are right there at the
tops of those Caverns that we call
nostrils and they are brain yeah
definitely it's it's the only place
where your brain meets the outside world
because in your retina they're protected
by by a lens and here here you have
neurons in contact with with the world
this this actually has been the source
for some
theories on a potential uh route for for
neurodegenerative
um mechanisms so as as you may know
um loss of the sense of smell is one of
the if not the earliest sign of
neurodegenerative disease
so for example in Parkinson's disease
there's uh uh loss in the sense of smell
probably 10 years before any other
symptom
um but people have failed to make this a
diagnostic tool because it's
non-specific
so it's not as if you could come to your
doctor and say I'm losing my sense of
smell and they'll say oh early sign of
Parkinson's because
you can have many reasons to lose your
sense of smell and and so on
um
but but
olfactory loss again is is an early sign
of neurodegeneration and there's at
least one Theory particularly about
Alzheimer's disease
suggesting that that Alzheimer's may be
the result of of a pathogen that enters
the brain through the olfactory system
um oh interesting it's it's not of
course a a mainstream or widely accepted
theory of any type but but it just
highlights this notion that that the
nose is a path to our brain
I think these non-invasive
um readouts of potential
neurodegeneration
um such as uh visual tests because of
the fact that the retinas are part of
the brain and loss of neurons in the
retina is often associated with other
forms of central generation Alzheimer's
Parkinson's Etc as it's a little more
invasive than what you're describing I'm
beginning to wonder why we don't
um get have a olfactory task every time
we go to the doctor
that would allow tracking over time
because of course as you mentioned
someone can lose their sense of smell
does that mean they're getting
Alzheimer's not necessarily but if their
sense of smell was terrific the year
before and it's 50 percent worse than
actually that's a really bad sign yeah
that's a bad sign and so what we're
talking about something completely
non-invasive and could be relatively
Pleasant to innocuous depending on the
odor's use so yeah so so first I can
answer that right and the reason that
that's not happened and that might that
that may be changing right now but the
reason that has not happen
is because olfaction has not been
effectively digitized
right so if you need to generate you
know really precise visual information
you can buy a monitor for you know 100
bucks that is it the resolution of the
visual system basically and if you want
to generate auditory stimuli really
precisely then you can buy an amplifier
for you know maybe a bit more than 100
bucks but not that much more
and you'll be at the resolution of the
auditory system
in our lab we build devices that
generate orders we call them all
factometers which is a misnomer because
they don't measure anything but that's
what they've always been called so we
call them all factometers as well
and we've already built at least one all
factometer that cost a quarter of a
million euro and it's pathetic right so
it just it's pathetic it's it's slow
it's contaminated it's nowhere near the
resolution of your system
so one of the reasons that's not
happened
is just
the utterly poor control of the stimulus
mind you to some extent it has happened
in that there there are a standard
clinical tests of olfaction basically
two that sort of control uh the world in
this respect the older one is is a test
called the upsit which stands for the
University of Pennsylvania smell
identification test
it was developed by Richard Dodie and
Penn and it's a test where you scratch
and sniff and it's a four alternative
forced choice test with 40 odorants so
you have these 40 pages that you page
through and you sniff and smell and and
um you know it's been normed on
gazillions of tests
um
I I'm always amused by it because so
Richard Dodie made a ton of money uh on
the upsit but he needed it because he
has a habit he has a NASCAR so this
every time we buy upsits and live I said
there's another gallon of gas into
Richard he races NASCAR it's not not
like NASCAR but like one lower than that
like I don't know like some some sort of
formula a or formula for it or something
he races a car and so that's where all
the ubsites went so I always feel good
about buying either PSATs because I know
they're going to that good cause but
keeping him in in in the fast lane yeah
but but so so that's one test that's out
there and indeed you know has been shown
as a you know so there's reduced upsit
and Alzheimer's and Parkinson's and and
then a host of other diseases and
there's a European version called
sniffing sticks
has developed and and it's it's
basically the same sort of concept of
that one isn't scratch and sniff it's
like these pens that you open up and and
sniff but but those exist but
they're not as as convenient as as uh
is delivering stimuli and vision and
audition and that's why you don't have
what you've just suggested
you know another thing another place
where you don't have it which which I
think is even more would have been even
more meaningful is
is you don't oh actually it's not tested
in in newborns right where vision and
audition is
you know there's this thing called
congenital anosomia right which is being
without the sense of smell from birth
supposedly in general
uh which is a half a percent of the
population
it's not a trivial number not totally
yeah
but nobody knows if that really is true
because here's an amazing factoid guess
the average age at which can General and
osmia
is diagnosed and this is this is a
horrible statistic for me for the way I
see the world but what do you think the
average age of diagnosis is for
congenital anosmia five years of age 14.
incredible 14. so most people who are
one half of a one percent of the human
population presumably yeah is uh without
the sense of smell and doesn't realize
that until they're 14 years old well I
don't know when they realized it first
but but it's formally diagnosed at 14 on
average which means some of them even
later right and um and uh right it's a
distribution well what um do they suffer
yes so so first of all
they they suffer socially
um and there's a host of of deleterious
life events associated with congenital
anosmia
um the the die younger
um the so it's it's it's uh it's this is
work out of uh Ilona Croy in Germany
um and you know amongst the various
things that are predicted by an osmia is
shorter lifespan uh but things like you
know reduced uh social contacts uh
reduced
um romantic social contacts
um it's not a good thing
um and and do they lack olfactory bulbs
I'm presenting they have noses and
nostrils there is a condition I'm aware
of where where uh children are born
without no very rare yeah very rare
focus on that because it's exceedingly
rare
um but they're born with noses and
nostables um and here's the thing right
we don't know if they're born with
olfactory bulbs
um most of them although not all of them
but most of them don't have olfactory
bulbs in adulthood or or I should
rephrase that have remnants olfactory
bulbs really shriveled olfactory bulbs
but you know nobody can say the cause
and effect here before we talk about the
role of the the uh requirement for
olfactory bulbs for olfaction a very
interesting topic in its own right I I'm
curious as to whether or not their
endocrine system is altered because as
we'll soon talk about there's a lot of
signaling through the nose
from between individuals that uh
triggers things everything from the
onset of puberty to feelings of romantic
attraction attachment these sorts of
things
um is it known whether or not and I
should say excuse me for interrupting
myself but as long as I'm interrupting
you every five minutes I might as well
interrupt myself too that um we are well
aware of the proximity of the olfactory
system to some of the hypothalamic
systems that regulate the release of
gonadotropins which control testosterone
and estrogen production Etc so um are
they uh hormonally normal so some are
and some aren't and I'll I'll be
specific so
um there's a condition known as common
syndrome
which is hypogonadic development
um in in men
and in Kalman syndrome uh they're
practically all announcement
so so to answer your question yes
there's a direct link and and it
materializes in common syndrome that
said not all congenital anosomic uh
individuals have common syndrome
and not all but almost all people who
have common syndrome are in osmaker so
so common syndrome uh goes with uh
anosmia I think so there is a female
equivalent of Commons or I don't
remember its name uh it's not turn it's
not a in the Turner syndrome family I'm
not sure okay and I think it's also
associated with anosmia uh but I'm not
confident of that but Commons is is
associated with an osmia uh so so the
answer is is yes and and you know we can
maybe you know
of action and reproduction are are
tightly linked and and they're tightly
Linked In all mammals and we are big
terrestrial mammals and all fashion
reproduction are linked in humans as
well
um yeah we will definitely get into that
I'd like to just take a brief moment and
thank one of our podcast sponsors which
is inside tracker inside tracker is a
personalized nutrition platform that
analyzes data from your blood and DNA to
help you better understand your body and
help you reach your health goals I've
long been a believer in getting regular
blood work done for the simple reason
that blood work is the only way that you
can monitor the markers such as hormone
markers lipids metabolic factors Etc the
impact your immediate and long-term
Health one major challenge with blood
work however is that most of the time it
does not come back with any information
about what to do in order to move the
values for hormones metabolic factors
lipids Etc into the ranges that you want
with inside tracker changing those
values becomes very straightforward
because it has a personalized dashboard
that you can use to address the
nutrition-based behavior-based
supplement-based approaches that you can
use in order to move those values into
the ranges that are optimal for you Your
vitality and your longevity inside
tracker now includes a measurement of
April lipoprotein B so-called APO B in
their ultimate plan APO B is a key
marker of cardiovascular health and
therefore there's extreme value to
knowing your apob levels if you'd like
to try inside tracker you can go to
insidetracker.com huberman to get 20 off
any of inside trackers plans again
that's inside tracker.com huberman to
get 20 off I have a story slash question
that I'd like to
um tell you ask you as a segue to that
noting of course that we'll get back to
the the requirement for olfactory bulbs
yes or no for olfaction uh and um this
really so when I was growing up I grew
up at the uh end of a street with a lot
of boys of my age who just by
coincidence had a lot of older sisters
were my sister my older sister's age it
was fortunate so I had a lot of kids to
play with we would hang out at each
other's houses bike build jumps and do
all those things like kid stuff Fort
stuff
get into trouble or whatnot
and oftentimes we would end up leaving
our articles of clothing at each other's
houses all the time like t-shirts and
jackets and so my mom was constantly
coming in and saying there's all there's
this close like someone left us here I
don't know who it was we were all more
or less the same size and
from the as far back as I could remember
six seven years old and onward I could
pick up a shirt or a jacket smell it and
say oh well that's Eric eisenhart's
shirt a friend of mine there I just gave
his name or oh that's Scott Madsen shirt
I I could just smell the shirt and in a
conscious way know who it belonged to
having never I promise not that I would
pretend if I had if I had
um pretend I hadn't if I had but having
never actually done the exercise of
going and taking and smelling my friend
intentionally right okay in fact if
anything I had all the reasons in the
world to avoid smelling to other young
boys in my neighborhood okay so yeah
um that raises the question of whether
or not we are consciously and or
subconsciously
coding identification of people that we
interact with frequently or infrequently
in terms of their smell
and or some other aspect of their um
chemistry yeah
so yes
um
we're doing that all the time in my view
and a lot of this processing almost all
of it is subconscious and I don't know
why already already put that out there
right I have no idea why why uh Human
Nature has has uh or nature or culture
or whatnot has has pushed this into the
realm of of subconscious and something
we're unaware of
um but we do it all the time and
um
in our lab has lots of studies on this
front
um one of them you may be familiar with
it that had gained some notoriety
because it's amusing
um so we
we look at human behavior a lot we try
to look at it through our news and in
the way we look at what people are doing
you know we try to think you know if I
was a dog
what what would I think of this and and
you know if you look at dogs right
they've you know when they interact they
visibly sniff each other it's very
obvious they walk up to each other and
they sniff each other
um
and yet humans don't typically walk up
to a stranger and carefully sniff them
right I mean it's we're sort of obliged
to sniff our our babies that's
considered almost something you're
supposed to do
um and it's not culturally taboo to
sniff our loved ones it sort of doesn't
seem like an odd thing to do
but we don't sniff strangers right well
or do we so we're finding more and more
mechanisms where we do this and the one
I'm referring to now for one example is
we started looking at handshaking
handshaking is this really odd behavior
and it's not only in the west by the way
some people think it's only a western
thing it's not it's almost everywhere
and and
there's really poor understanding of how
this Behavior evolved like where did
where did this thing come from so if you
you know if you look for the Wikipedia
version right then they'll tell you that
it's to show that you're not holding a
weapon in your hand but there's really
no good evidence for that it's a bit
like the trillion Bloodhound receptor
story right I mean we tried to find it
you know why do people say that and they
just do and we started looking at people
handshaking and and we noticed or it
seemed to us that we're noticing that
you know people will shake hands and
then we'll go like this and like for
those of you listening not watching them
no um it was taking his hand and and
wiping it on his face yeah grabbing his
nose or touching myself yeah these
things these things that we do all the
time after a handshake well so first of
all we do them all the time just period
right the Baseline here is really high
and we'll get to that in a second but
but but these behaviors that you know
you you could easily not notice right
and and so we we asked whether that's a
real thing
um
and this was a study led by John fruming
in our lab at the time
um
and what we did first and if you want we
can link so so this was published in
E-Life and one of the nice things about
E-Life is that it has a very effective
way to embed videos in the publication
so if you want we can link this to your
system later on even the show note
captions as a link on YouTube and the
other for uh platforms Spotify Apple so
so what we did is is
um we we brought in participants to our
lab
and we sat them in the room uh
experiment room
and and told them the experiment would
start soon and they should wait for us
there they didn't know what they were
coming from unbeknownst to them they
were already being videoed uh of course
later on they had the opportunity to to
not agree to us saving the video in
which case we would delete it
immediately or or letting us use it for
science or someone letting us use it for
more than science for for the video
that's now on elife
and and we walk into the room and say
okay just wait here I will be right back
with you uh to set up our experiment and
they would sit there for three minutes
and during those three minutes we could
later quantify how much indeed they just
by Baseline how much they touched their
nose or their forehead or their chin or
how many times their hands uh reaches
their face and by the way that Baseline
is not low okay
um and then three minutes later an
experimenter would walk into the room
and uh would share a consistent text it
would be you know we're still setting up
our equipment in the other room uh our
and and so just wait here and we'll be
right back with you but in the meantime
just wait here
and the experimenter went through this
like 20 second fixed text and in half of
the cases it included the handshake this
was a new experimenter not the one who
put them in the room so that's the first
time they met so it would be a little
I'm you know so and so they would put
out their hand and shake their hand or
not okay and we did all possible
interactions in terms of gender so we
matched male participants with male and
female experimenters and female
participants with female and male
experimenters and so you had handshake
and no handshake conditions and then you
can quantify that behavior of the hand
going to the nose after a handshake
and there was a remarkable increase in
the hand going to the news after
handshake and this is one of the nice
cases we the paper includes statistics
but you don't need statistics here just
look at the video it's on it's unreal
the video is unreal so interesting so
the hand goes to the nose now we did a
few controls here
to verify that this is an olfactory
Behavior one is unbeknownst into
participants we measured nasal airflow
and and people not only bring their hand
to their nose they sniff it so and this
is perfectly time they go like this okay
so they're sniffing their hands and in
an additional control study we
manipulated it so we built this little
James Bond thing of a watch on the
experimenter's hand they could emit an
odor and the experimenter didn't know
what odor they were emitting and they
could emit either a pleasant or an
unpleasant odor and we could drive the
self-sampling afterwards up or down so
this was an olfactory Behavior no doubt
about it I mean we're quite confident so
people in that case people must have
been sensing the odor on their own hand
because they'd Shake shook the hand of
the of the experimenter pleasant odor
and they're more frequently bringing
that hand to their nose versus
unpleasant odor that had been introduced
to their own hand by the experimenter
Yeah but no I think I think they were
sensing the the ambient odor that came
in with the hand that That Shook and
then that either drove them to snip
their more or less the odor cloud of the
expression yeah and there's an
interesting thing going on here too
because people didn't only smell The
Hand That Shook they also smelled the
other hand
and and we think that there's something
going on here comparing self to other
and we think a lot of self-sampling
might might reflect that there's on the
same line and again to to link to your
childhood story of of uh identifying
your friends by by smell
um
study we published just last year by uh
in battle Ravi in our lab
um
where inval came with this uh uh basic
interest in this phenomenon that's
Loosely referred to as click friendships
so people you meet and you click right
away right you immediately become close
friends and this is a phenomena that you
know is poorly described or is poorly
ascribed in literature as as an entity
and yet anybody will tell you they know
what you're talking about right I mean
if you tell you know if somebody you
click with right away you you become
intimate within five minutes right
everybody experienced this in their life
you know to some extent
and the question is what what was there
right what was it was it because you
looked the same could be was it because
you know you had the same sports team
that you liked or is there something uh
uh deeper here and and in Buzz theory
was that that
um
that a similarity in body order May
contribute to this
that people who smell the same will
click in some way and so to address that
she actually recruited uh
um click friends from all over Israel
she posted all of her social media uh to
identify uh
pairs of friends so these are our
same-sex non-romantic diets so these are
friends men and women uh whose
friendship started is a click
where here this becomes sensitive
because it has to be a mutual click
right later on we discovered there could
be one-sided clicks so if somebody's
sure they clicked with somebody else but
the other person there's a name for that
in neurology that our uh common friend
the late Ben Barris taught me which is
there's a phrase that neurologists use
okay called sticky these are people that
come up to you and and start asking you
questions and then won't leave you alone
they're so-called sticky people that and
if you ask these sticky people
um sticky in air quotes because they're
not physically sticky
um maybe what they could be
um you know
what do you think of the per this person
they'll say oh they're great we're
really good friends and so they've made
a unilateral um click friendship yeah
yeah and uh yes neurologists are talking
about you if you're if you're one of
these people neurologists are talking
about you there's a an informal
diagnostic code sticky so so so uh she
she recruited
um
click friends
and then she sampled their body odor and
and we have a a protocol for this so
they're given you know uh odorless
shampoo and soap to use for three weeks
or something and then they sleep two
nights in this t-shirt uh where they
have to sleep alone and then we extract
the body odor from the t-shirt and so we
have a way to extract a method to
extract body odor and then she she first
asked
um whether indeed
click friends are more similar in their
body order than you would expect by
chance
and she first tested this with them with
a device a machine we call an electronic
nose so an electronic nose is sort of a
very poor effort to mimic what the
mammalian nose does basically it's a
bunch of sensors that respond to
Airborne molecules in this case sensors
referred to as moxers as a metal oxide
covered sensors
um
and so she used an electronic nose to
sample these body odors and she found
that click friends are indeed more
similar to each other than you would
expect by chance by random diets and
this was a significant difference and
after she found that a device could do
this
she had other participants do this so so
she had people smelling the click
friends versus non-click friends and and
they judge them as being more similar to
each other
uh than not now again you you might
wonder is this causal or not right
because maybe click friends go to the
same restaurant together or all the time
or whatever or live in the same
neighborhood and and that's why they
they they smell the same so to address
causality she recruited total strangers
and first smell them with the electronic
nose and then engage them in a social
interaction something called the mirror
game so in the mirror game one person
moves their hands and the other person
is really close to them like right here
so they can smell each other and has to
move their hands with the other person
and one one prediction there panned out
uh but another didn't the one that
didn't so she predicted that people
would smell more uh similar to each
other would be better at the mirror game
that is they would follow each other
better that did not pan out however
she then also had the interaction was
completely non-verbal they were not
allowed to speak with each other and she
did an entire round robin so everybody
played with everybody else this was an
insane experiment to run
and
and she then at the end of the
experiment each person raided each other
person as to how much they think they
would want to be their friends and also
on a bunch of ratings how nice they
think they are how affectionate they
think a bunch of ratings okay
all of this was predicted by the
electronic news so people who smell more
similar to each other think that the
other person is more likely to be their
friend is more likely to be a nice
person etc etc so we could actually
predict friendship using the electronic
news so this is not a result of
friendship it's it plays into the causal
elements of of building friendship so
this is to relate to your childhood
story uh there's something going on here
we're constantly smelling ourselves
constantly this
constantly so I mean if you want to like
I don't know the reason I'm smiling I
mean and your viewers are listeners will
understand why I'm smiling I'll send you
a video to link uh uh in in the in into
your podcast here we thought of calling
the the fact that people constantly
sniff themselves we thought of calling
this the low effect and low so in
America this won't pass that effectively
but in in the rest of the normal world
is the soccer the national soccer coach
of the German soccer team so
yeah I mean I don't know who would be a
very famous coach here but Steve Kerr I
mean this is the choice this is a super
super famous uh name all around the
world where soccer is the primary sport
that people watch
um
and and once people will see this video
they'll understand why we thought of
calling this the low effect uh it's a
very graphic uh but but people are
constantly smelling themselves they're
smelling themselves with their hands
they're smelling themselves explicitly
people are constantly smelling
themselves constantly smelling others
um I find this topic so interesting um
and first of all confession I definitely
smell myself multiple times per day and
everybody does okay good yeah and I I um
I would do it anyway
um uh I think I like most people I
either find my own smell to be neutral
to Pleasant
right I um occasionally I'll be like
well I need to take a shower as long as
we're talking about smelling oneself and
um friendship kinship and its
relationship to smell we have to talk
about the relationship between smell and
romantic attraction and bond so my
understanding is that if for instance a
mouse is given the option to mate with
any number of other different mice
they will bias their choice toward the
mouse that has the immune composition
the so-called MHC major
histocomatibility complex which reflects
immune diversity the immune system that
is most distant from theirs and the The
evolutionary argument being that were
they to
um produce offspring that the array of
immune genes would be much broader than
if they were to select an animal very
close to them and in addition to that
that one of the most strongly selected
against behaviors not just culturally
but at the level of eliciting a sense of
disgust
maybe even from the activity of the
hypothalamus is mating with very close
kin AKA incest because that can
potentially we know produces a higher
rate of mutations in other words whereas
you describe the relationship between
smell and choice of friends as you uh
choose people who smell more like you my
understanding is that in the context of
uh
choosing romantic Partners or sexual
partners or both that you choose the
person who's odor and therefore immune
composition is most different right so
the way you describe the animal
literature is correct
and there's evidence to similar
mechanisms in humans our lab has not
worked directly on this issue of of uh
of uh romantic selection based on odor
um there's a bunch of papers
um wedkins Ed Allen and the wedkin lab
and also Porter I'll I'll email these to
you later on
um that have have done a lot of this
work and find exactly as you say that
that um um romantic order preferences in
humans are influenced by Body order and
that this is linked to MHC uh uh is the
compatibility complex makeup of the the
portion of our genome that that shapes
our immune system uh to some extent
um so so this effect
um has been studied and reported on
again extensively in mice and also uh in
in humans
um
not work that that we've done
the one sort of
tangent work we've done and and
I'd like to maybe tell you about
it relates to to an effect
that that is one of the most remarkable
effects in in mammalian social chemo
signaling so
and and also related to to so it's it's
not related to Romanticism in any way or
or but but it's related to reproduction
and and indeed in our lab we've not
looked at Romanticism we have looked at
or are looking at reproduction
they're not always the same
um certainly
oh they can they can animal mammalian or
terrestrial mammalian reproductive
behavior is is dominated by by the sense
of smell
um in in mammals and here remember
initially when you started off I I noted
that there are several subsystems in our
news that transduce utterance and and so
primarily the manual factory system
which is cranial nerve number one and
the trigeminal nerve which is cranial
number five
um most terrestrial mammals have another
subsystem referred to as the the
secondary olfactory system
that has a separate sense organ in the
nose this organ is known as the
vulnerable nasal organ
it's a small pit in the nasal passage of
of most terrestrial mammals sometimes
it's uh described as a communicating pit
because sometimes it connects the nasal
passage to the roof of the mouth
sometimes it can it connects both
and
so there's this sense organ with its
specific receptor subtypes uh vnr's
vermonasal receptors
and uh this
um
um is linked to a to a sort of separate
portion of the olfactory bulb not really
a manual Factory bubble it's referred to
as the accessory olfactory bulb
um and from there directly to the limbic
system to the to the portions of the
brain that control reproductive Behavior
Uh and aggressive behavior and
and in most
um terrestrial mammals this subsystem
processes utterance there are sometimes
referred to as pheromones although
that's in many ways a problematic term
but but utterance that are referred to
as pheromones namely odorants that are
emitted by another member of the species
to influence that member of the species
and alter Behavior or hormonal state
and
and and some of these pheromonal effects
are are utterly remarkable and in my
view the most remarkable of all is an
effect known as the Bruce effect
uh this was an effect discovered by
Margaret Bruce in 1959 she was a British
scientist
and in the Bruce effect when you expose
a pregnant Mouse
at an early critical stage of the
pregnancy
um I think up to about day three uh if
you expose the pregnant Mouse uh to the
order of what is referred to in
technical terms is the non-stud male
that is a male who did not father the
pregnancy
she will miscarry the pregnancy she will
abort it
now that that's an insane decision made
by the female here right because she's
invested quite a lot in this right in in
biological terms and in in forming this
pregnancy and maintaining it and yet she
drops it on the basis of an odor
um and this effect is remarkably robust
and what do I mean by remarkably robust
so this will occur
on about 80 percent of exposures now as
you know 80 is 100 in biology right I
mean there's nothing that happens at
more than 80 percent
so it's a remarkably remarkably robust
effect this this dropping of the
pregnancy and we know it's mediated by
chemosensation three no for sure and we
know in the following way so first it's
enough to just bring the order of the
non-stead male you don't have to bring
the mail himself right so you just can
bring bedding from a nonsense male and
that will induce uh the Bruce effect but
of course uh the most telling set of
experiments is that if in the female
Mouse you ablate the vulner nasal organ
you just burn this tiny structure in the
nose and the effect disappears so the
effect is completely dependent on the
former nasal organ
um
and and I find this out really a
remarkable effect right I mean because
again because of the the extent of of
cost that the female takes on here uh
based on on this information and smell
now
humans
the the sort of the going notion in all
faction is that humans don't have a
functional vomarinasal organ
so we don't have that functional organ
in our nose now I'll point out we
actually do have
the pit
so the the structure or the outlining
structure is there
uh but the pit that we have is
considered vestigial and non-functional
and what about this thing I learned
about at Berkeley uh in integrative
biology class that we have something
called Jacobson's organ this is the same
organ so so Jacobson Orion is the former
nasal organ uh it's also called Jacobson
because
um I think Jacobson was a military
physician in like the 1800s in Holland
or something and he found it in in
in a soldier who was operating on or
something like that the the story comes
from something like that but but
Jacobson organ is another name for the
former known as organ these are one and
the same the sensory organ of the
accessory olfactory system and again the
going notion is that the human Jacobson
organ or Romanus organ is vestigial it's
non-functional does that necessarily
mean that we don't have these pheromone
effects no it does not so first of all
we know that lots of what are considered
pheromonal effects namely social chemo
segolian rodents are mediated by the
manual factory system we know that for
sure
um there are several examples for this
in mice and rats and rabbits and so on
and so forth so so a uh these can be
mediated by by the manual factory system
and and I'll I'll come back to that in a
second but first to finish the the Bruce
effect
um
and and second and and I'm going out on
a limb here uh but I'm willing to take
that that uh risk I'm I'm for me the
jury is still out on human vulner nasal
organ
um the the decision or the the notion uh
that it's non-functional relies on about
one and a half papers
postmortem uh looking for the nerve that
connects this thing to the brain and
failing to find it using staining and so
on and so forth but sustaining
postmortem studies in humans are are
notoriously
complicated
um basically you know for many reasons
one of them is that the material is just
always has gone through you know it's
it's not ideally uh uh set as it is when
you sacrifice an animal and and
and and study its its tissue
um so so based on on really really a
positive studies that fail to find uh
this nerve the notion is that the
structure is vestigial uh in humans I
don't have any evidence that it's
functional mind you but but I'm just not
sure that it's not but
um what we do have a suspicion
is that humans may experience something
similar to Bruce effect
so
first of all humans have an enormous
um number or ratio of of spontaneous
miscarriage are they
um occurring more often in the first
trimester because you mentioned yes that
in the Bruce effect in the mice is in
the first three days or so following
pregnancy which in the mouse gestation
as I recall is about 21 days in the
mouse you're talking about one-seventh
of total gestation so I'm I'm not quick
enough to to nor is it important to
translate but this would be first
trimester yes which is indeed when most
miscarriage occurs now humans have again
a huge number of miscarriages and and
the numbers I'll soon share them with
you they sound odd and the reason they
sound odd is because if if you have
what's sometimes simply referred to as
failed implantation right this can occur
you know in days one two nobody ever
knows okay so so some papers talk about
90 of all human pregnancies end in
miscarriage this is counting a failed
implementation in day one two Etc more
conservative studies talk about 50
percent nobody will argue 30 okay so a
huge number a huge number of of uh human
pregnancies end in miscarriage
now out of these there's a portion
that are are unexplained right so nobody
knows why I mean there are portions that
are explained by all sorts of genetic
factors developmental factors and so on
and so forth but there's also a
proportion that are unexplained
and and and so all I'm saying is that
there's there's a statistical backdrop
or setting if you will force something
like a Remnant Bruce effect in humans
now with that in mind we we approach the
group
um
of we we enlisted a group of of they're
not really patients and participants in
a study of people who or couples who are
experiencing what is referred to as as
unexplained repeated pregnancy loss
so formally if you have uh two
consecutive uh unexplained miscarriages
then uh that that is sufficient for the
diagnosis of unexplained repeated
pregnancy loss
however in our cohort of 30 we had
couples who experienced 12 consecutive
unexplained repeated pregnancy losses so
so the two the two is just the formal
all of our cohort was like twelve five
you know so this is an emotional
difficult place to be
and and these are couples who who are
losing uh their pregnancy for no
apparent reason so they've gone through
all the tests that you can imagine of
you know genetic incompatibilities and
all sorts of issues uh clotting all the
all the the known suspects uh for for
pregnancy Lawson the the medical
establishment remains totally at a loss
as to why these pregnancies aren't
holding and so we hypothesized that that
perhaps here there's something akin to
to a Bruce type effect obviously it's
not going to be the same as in mice but
but something like a Bruce effect now of
course at that stage we could not do
anything causal to to test this right
but what we could do is to see uh you
know to seek circumstantial evidence to
see if if where there's fire maybe
there's smoke and what we did was we
tested uh
olfaction and more specifically the
response to male body odor uh in in the
the couples experiencing
um
uh repeated pregnancy loss and
we found a few things first of all if
you think of the mechanisms behind the
Bruce effect
the Bruce effect implies that the female
has to have a very clear memory
of uh the following meal because if
she's gonna miscarry in response to the
non-father she has to know father
non-father I mean that means that
there's a pronounced olfactory memory at
the moment of mating okay and in mice
this has been very well characterized
and and attributed to the Ontario
olfactory nucleus a structure in the
brain
um
but you'd have to have this memory in
order to make that decision
now so to address that and here you're
going to see that you in your childhood
story from before stand out a bit as as
skillful
is that the first thing we did was just
behaviorally test uh whether
um
these women and control women
could identify the smell of their uh
spouse
[Music]
and you might be disappointed or you
know it we would all are probably a bit
disappointed to learn that control where
I'm in uh are very poor at this
so so you you would think that that
women would be good at identifying the
body order of their spouse they're not
uh they're not far from chance
however
um the uh women who experience uh
repeated pregnancy loss
are more than they're they're double uh
at their performance level so this is
not a Nuance effect
uh women who who who experience repeated
uh pregnancy loss can identify uh their
husbands or their spouses uh by their
body odor
with much greater Acuity than the
typical person double
a bit more than double and way above
chance yeah no I I sorry I posed as a
question but I meant yes with much
greater Acuity uh and double is is a
significant
um Improvement
are they much better at detecting any
odor no they're not we did the controls
and they're not
and then
um we also measured using fmri we
measured their their brain response to
uh stranger male body odor
and there and and and this was quite
remarkable because you know we
approached so this was a full brain
analysis so without a region of Interest
analysis so it's not as if you're uh
tweaking your statistics to look at one
part of the brain you're just looking at
the entire brain in the response to male
body order and asking de novo is there a
difference between these two groups of
participants and there was one huge
difference and it was in the
hippothalamus and so there was a
difference in response to stranger male
body order uh between the two groups
um
so so
olfaction is altered in spontaneous
repeated spontaneous uh pregnancy loss
we don't know this is causal right uh
but but
that was enough for us to approach the
Ethics Committee
um to run a causal experiment
um and we're at the beginning of that
now
incredible I can't wait to hear the the
results of that it's gonna take it'll
probably take years
um a few because because
the these are slow experiments to run uh
um recruitment is complicated uh but
basically we're we're blocking
um
we're blocking smell in in uh couples
who are trying to maintain a pregnancy
I want to touch on some other so-called
pheromone effects and one thing I heard
you say during a talk which I think
really captures this whole issue of are
there pheromone effects in humans
um very nicely as you said you know
whether or not it's a classic pheromone
effect or whether or not it's olfaction
or something else this is chemos sensory
signaling between individuals um the
reason this is important to me is a few
years ago I did a social media post
about pheromone effects and animals and
some potential pheromone effects in
humans and a couple of the um human uh
olfactionistas
um more from the the actually who work
on animal models really came after me
with um you know intense sniffing saying
uh you know there is no evidence for
human pheromone effects human pheromone
organs and I think today you've
beautifully Illustrated how regardless
of the answer to that
humans are
contain and are emitting chemical
signals that influence each other's
physiology and behavior for sure for
sure and and the the term pheromone is a
problematic term in any case I mean the
term the term was
um put forth to describe insect Behavior
right so you know if if you were given a
hard time by the mouse people you could
have given them an equally hard time if
you were an insect person right because
really the place the term is is uh is
accurate is you know so the first
pheromone that was discovered was
bambicol which is the pheromone that has
the male moth follow the the scent Trail
of the female moth
is a pheromone
um
insect pheromone people will argue that
this stuff that people talk about in
mice and rats is not pheromones I see
and and it all becomes semantics yeah
sort of like nerdy inside ball it's all
semantics so I don't I in our
Publications we don't use the term
pheromone you know because it would not
help me and it would probably only hurt
us and so you know we talk about chemo
signals and humans definitely emit chemo
signals from their body
and these chemo signals influence other
humans and influence their behavior you
know in in
there are several examples of this one
of them I'll point out first
which is is sort of the most widely
studied and and not mostly from our lab
actually I mean the the flavor of the
month for the past 10 years in this
field
is what's referred to as the smell of
fear right so
um
this is probably true of of many mammals
and humans uh it's true of
um we emit a specific body odor when
we're in a state of fear uh this was
first discovered in humans by Denise
Chen
um out of I think Brown I'm not sure
think that's right yep humans emit a
particular body odor when they're in a
state of fear and this body order
influences other humans in effect
increasing uh their autonomic uh arousal
their sympathetic State
um so in effect you could say that fear
is contagious a bit so the smell of fear
is contagious by the way culturally uh
we know for ages that dogs can smell if
you're in humans but actually that was
only really shown about a year and a
half ago in a study so it was always
said but it wasn't really shown
effectively it was shown about a year
and a half ago in a study the dogs
indeed can smell human fear
um and humans can smell human fear so
several Labs starting from Denise Chen
and Javelin Jones and and then in our
lab and in other labs if you collect
body odor from people in a state of fear
uh and collect body order from the same
people when they're not in a state of
fear other people can determine which is
is the state of fear or and this
influences their behavior what about the
smell of safety or is that simply the
absence of the odor corresponding to
fear and the reason I ask this is
somewhat woven into our
um prior discussion about mate Choice
um again I'll ask the question in a form
of of brief anecdotes
um I'll use the I had a friend who uh
approach here but um well one phenomenon
that has nothing to do uh with me in
particular I think this is a common
phenomenon is
um
romantic Partners leaving articles of
clothing at each other's homes now this
could have other purposes to Mark
territory but um visually marking
territory but also um scent marking
territory is very common in the animal
kingdom
um it's not uncommon uh for uh romantic
Partners when one is traveling or away
for the other partner to smell their
article of clothing in order to bring
about positive uh connotations of the
other partner very common Behavior if
you're doing this folks other people are
doing this too yeah um it raises
questions for instance about whether or
not the morning period part post breakup
whether by decision by death or by
um some other phenomenon that's forced
to break up whether or not that morning
period has something to do with an
olfactory unlearning of uh um and made
slash and on and on and on with all
these insights I would offer you to be a
postdoc well
finished so I would love to do it but
it's going to kill me yeah exactly you
don't want me to work for you we talked
about this that's what I'm saying
that don't really work uh earlier I was
just I was afraid of the fact that I've
had three incredible scientific mentors
uh undergraduate graduate and postdoc
but
um for reasons uh that are unclear to me
um uh the first one died of suicide the
second one cancer at 50 and the third
one
um pancreatic cancer in his early 60s
and the last one before he died was an
MD and a common friend of gnomes and I
turned to me and said you know Andrew
you're the common denominator so um you
know that the joke
so nonetheless I would love to do a
sabbatical in your life so so what I was
trying to say in that round about way is
that those are all really Keen
observations and good ideas
um for sure and and and they just
highlight again you know that that we're
incredibly olfactory animals you know
and and and you're you're even talking
about the Nuance we're very ol' Factory
even not in the Nuance I mean I have
this when people tell me that you know
that we don't use our sense of smell and
we don't need it and all that and I I
have to deal with this a lot right I
have to deal a lot you study Vision
nobody will tell you that vision is
unimportant right I have to visually
dependent I don't need a dog to take
over my olfactory system if I lose old
faction but I'll tell you from having
lost my sense of smell for one day right
I was in intense fear I bit into a blue
I love blueberries I'm like a drive-by
blueberry either if they're there I just
kind of picked them up like a grizzly
bear and cram them in my mouth so keep
them away from me if you don't want them
eaten but I can't I almost can't help
myself
um I bit into a blueberry or a handful
of blueberries and they just it was the
sensation of little bags of water and I
immediately felt like tremendous
tremendous grief I'll tell you a sort of
a throwy line that I use in this when I
talk with people you know I mean you
know take the two most basic behaviors
that sustain us right let's say I give
you a choice
between
a beautiful looking
layer cake with with with strawberries
and blueberries and and uh and whipped
cream
but the smells of sewage
versus some gray brown mix that smells
of cinnamon which do you eat oh simple
right you eat the latter right now
imagine I offer you a mate choose the
the gender of your liking right it looks
like a Greek god or goddess right but
smells of sewage
or an ordinary looking individual that
smells of sin itself who do you choose
the latter right so in the two most
basic behaviors we have we follow our
nose not our eyes right definitely not
always in predictable ways because you
offered an extreme example which is the
best example but I for instance for
reasons I don't know I've never liked
the smell of perfume ever
in fact I find it aversive but I do I
confess I do like the smell of certain
body odors very much and I'm very
um particular about that and I know
within an instant
um and so uh this is a problem for any
romantic partner uh who likes perfume
for me but I know many people like
perfumes and colognes and things and In
fairness I've also been told
um that uh by someone that they couldn't
spend time with me because they do not
like my smell in fact they dislike it
and I unfortunately for me there's at
least one person on the planet who said
yes
so the um so I completely agree with
what you're saying yeah
um I can also say that um I imprinted on
the smell of my I had a Bulldog Mastiff
um when I raised from the time he was a
puppy and I imprinted on I imprinted on
his smell immediately and even though to
other people it was a Bulldog Mastiff
after all his smell was rather averse to
me he he smelled delicious right and it
made me it smelled like home and he was
my best animal friend for a long time so
and on and on and on right the smell of
children as you said the backs we had a
guest on this podcast who I'm sure
you're familiar with Charles Zucker yeah
a professor Columbia has done incredible
work and vision and old-fashioned yeah
they're sensing it and he and I talked a
little bit about this that
um there's something in the breath
of romantic Partners
um that's hopefully a pettitive not
aversive as well as in children he was
talking about the smell of his
grandchild's the bat the nape of their
the back of their neck and how he misses
that smell because when he thinks about
missing his grandchild or children it's
that smell that that that's associated
with that feeling hexadecanal
hexadecanal yes is it Charles your
grandchildren smell like hexadecanal yes
he's gonna come after me now and so this
this is a steady uh ran by uh Eva
mishore who was a graduate student in
our lab
um
and and Eva was interested in aggression
she was really into aggression
um and actually when she start and and
when she start off we said okay let's do
chemo signaling of aggression
she actually was going to like MMA clubs
and collecting body odors
uh and we we had all sorts of ideas
going and and she she worked on that for
quite a bit it never went anywhere
really
and then
at the same time
we had a colleague of ours from Germany
I mean when I say colleague primarily a
friend or acquaintance I made it
conferences
um
Heinz Breer
um and and um
he was studying in his lab
a molecule hexadecanal
um that was a chemo signal in mice
where in mice it was described as a
chemo signal that promotes social
buffering where social buffering as far
as I understand it's not my field but as
far as I understand it's basically a
feel-good together thing so when lots of
whites are together they feel good about
being in a group and that's social
buffering and it's promoted by
hexadecanal which they emit in their
feces mice
and in his work on hexadecanal
um and and so so Brier and his colleague
swordsman they discovered the receptor
for this and then they went and
discovered that the receptor is very
highly conserved throughout mammalian
Evolution and therefore they
hypothesized that maybe
um this is a universal mammalian signal
now which is unusual because in in chemo
signaling typically you tend to think of
things as being very species specific
but here they're hypothesized that maybe
hexadecanal which promotes social
buffering in mice may do something in
all mammals again because this receptor
is very highly conserved or 37b I think
um so they so he approached us and said
look you got to study this stuff in
humans right because he knows us as the
human people right I mean we go to these
old-fashioned conferences where where
lots of people study mice and and
zebrafish and whatnot and we're the the
human group
so and and eventually he just fedexed us
hexadecanal
and and so we had this thing sitting
around and Eva was not going anywhere
with her aggression studies with sweat
from Human participants
and yet she built the entire
um Paradigm to study human aggression so
their standard paradigms this is a
paradigm known as the tap the Tyler
aggression Paradigm I'll soon describe
it
and so we said okay we have this
hexadecanal stuff here and it promotes
social buffering social buffering sounds
like it would make you less aggressive
why don't you run your TAP experiment
using hexadecanal
what's the tap experiment so basically
what you do is you bring in a
participant to lab and you have them
um
thinking that they're going to be
playing against another person in in
this game and you can you can do
something like have another person walk
into the other room playing online so so
connected so you can fool them into
being quite convinced that this is
what's happening and they go into their
own room
and in the initial game they play
um on each round their uh they're
provided with a sum of money and this is
real money that they'll receive at the
end of the experiment
and by turn each one of them decides how
to divide the money up between the two
right so they're playing against another
person they think but that's actually a
computer algorithm that they're playing
against and the
computer algorithm is is programmed to
be in in scientific terminology a jerk
right so that you know like let's say
they have to divvy up 100 cheko which is
the Israeli currency so so the com you
know the other player would say okay you
know um I'll keep 96 and you get four
right and then if you can either accept
it
or not accept and then neither of you
get anything right so basically you're
being shafted by by the other side all
the time and this is called the
provocation phase you're really getting
angry at this person because they're
they're really not nice right they're
they're shafting you on every trial or
almost
and you play this game and it goes to
its end and then you click you play a
second game as far as you know against
the same participant and the second game
is a reaction time game so a Target
shows up and the first to press it wins
and on every trial where you win if you
want you can blast the other parts spent
with a loud noise
and and it's a really loud noise so
you're also wearing earphones it's 90 DB
and it's it's a screeching horrible
sound it's the most punishment that an
IRB committee will let you uh endure on
on a participants and experiment unless
you're in Stanford
70 years ago or whatever that was I was
referring to the classic prisoner
experiment which took place in the
building next door to where I work
so you can blast the other participant
with varying levels of sound and you
have a selection box from something very
low to something very high and what's
nice about this is that it then allows
you to quantify aggression because the
more volume you're blasting the opponent
was the more aggressive you are towards
your opponent and and so you have a
measure of aggression again the Tyler
aggression Paradigm obviously invented
by Tyler uh very well validated studied
all over you know a very standard
protocol
so we broaden participants and had them
play uh the title of the tap uh either
under exposure to hexadecanal or control
now access that Canal doesn't it's it's
incredibly difficult to even detect
Texas now but just in case uh because it
it it's not very very it's considered a
semi-volatile it doesn't have a strong
smell
um but we buried it both the control and
the hexadecan island in a control order
that hid them in a mask
and and she ran lots and lots and lots
and lots of participants men and women
and I'll first tell you the result with
men which is that hexadecanal
consistently reduced aggression
people were less aggressive under
hexadecanal
um the effect size was was uh uh quite
meaningful and later on we learned
because I'm no
specialist in the world of aggression
but compared to effects seen in the
aggression World in research really
really strong effects so unusually
strong
so hexadecanal lowered aggression in men
and we were like well this is you know
sort of what we were hoping to see
consistent with the hypothesis uh and
consistent with it seems to do in mice
but then we looked at data from women
and hexadecanal increased aggression
equally significantly is this thought to
be something related to maternal
protectiveness we're getting there so
you you got there really fast it took me
a year but and and ever got to it really
I'll I'll tell you because remember
we're reaching the back of the head of
your of
one of the kingpins of the New York
Neuroscience Mafia yes so
um
so this was really odd to me at that
time so I didn't have the intuition you
just had and I was like about this there
was some bug here I mean this this it
makes no sense to me you know why would
something increase aggression in women
and decrease aggression in men this is
really really strange
and and I said okay I want to see this
happen again before you know we go ahead
with this so she went and did the entire
experiment again and this time she did
it within the fmri magnet so that we we
can also uh track uh brain activity uh
while this was happening
and first of all it replicated again so
once again uh hexadecan element made men
less aggressive and women more
aggressive and and the extent of more
than the effect alone the dissociation
was remarkable this has the it's almost
like a chromosomal test I mean you you
look at the data on the unit unit slope
line and all all the men are below and
all the women are above there's this
figure in the paper then she also looked
at the brain data and this is you know
Although our lab does a ton of fmri it's
one of the major tools we use to measure
uh uh brain activity I'm I'm quite
cognizant of the limitations of fmri
and and this is I think sadly I think
the only study in my career at least
where where I actually managed to also
get a mechanism out of fmri not only
an area that's involved in activity
and and so here's what we saw that
hexadecanal alone
increased activity
quite pronouncedly in an area of the
brain known as the left angular gyrus
now this is an area involved in what's
referred to as social appraisal so that
was kind of cool in that a social order
activated the social brain not the
olfactory system per se and and very
pronounced
so on one hand that was cool but then
what was uncool was that it did the same
in men and women
and this was in contrast to behavior
which you don't like seeing right I mean
because you would expect brain activity
to reflect Behavior
and it increased activity in the left
angular gyrus in both both men and women
but then she did a follow-up analysis
which was look at what's referred to as
functional connectivity that is how does
this region of the brain talk with the
entire brain as it were under
hexadecanal versus uh control
and here the dissociation re-emerged
powerfully whereby the connectivity from
the angular gyrus was mostly to the
classic neural substrates of aggression
so the amygdala and the temporal Pole
and the connectivity went in opposite
directions in men and women so
hexadecanal increased functional
connectivity in men and decreased it in
women
so in a way this is almost saying that
the default brain reaction is aggression
right the default is to aggress and in
men hexadecanal increases the control
that the left angular virus is holding
over your aggression and keeping you
back and in women it let it roam free
and they became more aggressive
but I was still Apostle so so I was
convinced this happened twice the mro
data provided not only a pattern but a
mechanism which is unusual
and yet I I was telling Eva you know but
you know this makes no sense to me and
then and then her Insight which of
course afterwards is like duh it is no
there's a place where this makes perfect
sense and that is if you're a mammalian
Offspring because
paternal aggression is often directed at
you there is infanticide all over and
sadly there's male aggression towards
human children as well
and maternal aggression is often
protective
so if you're an offspring if you have a
molecule that will make your mother more
aggressive in your daddy less aggressive
both of those are good for you so you're
winning
so we remembered a recently published
paper from a group in Japan
that looked at the odors emanating from
baby heads we now come full circle to
sucker's grandchildren
they used a method known as gcms gas
chromatography Mass spectrometry to
measure the volatiles from baby heads
because baby head odor is a cultural
thing across cultures even in Japan
and so we quickly went to that paper and
to see if one of the molecules that
report is hexadecanal and we were very
disappointed that it wasn't one of the
molecules they reported in the paper
and so we wrote to the authors who are
since then our co-authors uh and we said
look you know we're studying uh this
molecule hexadecanon we don't see in
your results and and we were wondering
maybe you had some results that you
didn't publish or some supplementary
materials or whatever
and this lab which is a hardcore GC lab
said no no hexadecanal is a
semi-volatile which we knew uh in our
previous paper was not directed to the
semi-volatile range but we can now do
use what's called gcx GC WGC that is
directed at semi volatiles and we can do
this again we just uh studied 11 babies
and we can we can see if this is an
issue so he said yeah please do uh the
bottom line of all this is that
hexadecanal is the most abundant
semi-volatile in baby hits It's tons of
it coming out of baby hits so babies
again speaking about if humans do or
don't chemo single babies are conducting
chemical warfare right they're they're
they're
you know reducing
aggression in their fathers or males
around them and increasing aggression in
their mothers or females around them and
both of those things are good for them
incredible
this is somewhat different than what
we're talking about
um and yet similar in other ways because
it's uh built off of anecdotal evidence
but it's anecdotal evidence that you
hear all the time and yet when you look
in the scientific literature at least by
my read
the data are not clear maybe even
contradictory and that relates to the
coordination of menstrual cycles among
co-housed yeah women or women who are
friends the you know many women
listening to this and maybe some men who
are aware of of this effect will say oh
yeah absolutely when I spend time with
my friends or go away camping or even
spend a day with them our menstrual
cycles become coordinated
however
my understanding is that the early
literature Barbara McClintock correct
um discovered this phenomenon published
a paper in science as an undergraduate
1971 nature amazing nature paper again
one of the three Apex journals and as an
undergrad fantastic so discover this
describe this and probably women all
over the world who became aware of this
one way or another probably probably
said yes absolutely this gives
validation to what we've observed over
and over again and yet as subsequent
papers have been published this result
has been called into question is uh is
there any uh final word on whether or
not menstrual cycles uh become
coordinated among women who spend time
together and if so is there any role of
olfaction in this uh or chemosensing
through the nostrils or end or mouth
um to support this idea so so yeah so so
I'll start off indeed to Echo uh the
background is that this study was
conducted by by Martha McClintock when
she was an undergraduate Wesleyan
College uh and she noticed that she
thought her menstrual cycle and her
co-inhabitants in her dorm room
um
um were coordinated in time
um and I should say that this comes on
the basis of similar or related type
effects in rodents now ruins don't have
a menstrual cycle like humans do
um but but
um
there's a an effect in runes referred to
as the whiten effect which
um resembles uh this type of of effect
um and she published indeed that paper
as an undergraduate in nature in 1971
and to answer your question she
published a follow-up in 1998 also in
nature uh with then her graduate
students Chicago uh Stern so this is
Stern and McClintock 1998 and here's
what they did they collected
um sweat from donor women
and deposited it on the upper lip of
recipient women so this would be a fun
experiment for you at least because you
said you like body orders but for many
others perhaps it would be daunting well
I like certain body orders from certain
individuals
um I don't know I don't think I
uniformly like all body orders although
I do send a uniformly not like the smell
of perfume although I should just to
clarify because I put this out there and
I learned the hard way in the comment
section on YouTube some of those
perfumes I find downright aversive yeah
like it's a uh I think the great Marcus
Meister who a great neurobiologist once
said there's basically three responses
it's either yum yuck or meh so some are
true yeah I've never heard that one yeah
that one right in terms of the animal
behavior yeah
or pause
um so some are truly a yuck
some many are meh zero to date
or
yum for me now body odors the
distribution is shifted it could be any
one of those three yum yuck or meh so
just to be clear but the the um yum
category is definitely included
thank you
so uh um
so so she did this study so so because
right in the original McClintock study
you might suspect other uh drivers of
the effect let's see if you accept the
effect but still there might be other
social drivers of the effect there are
not body odor right there might be some
dominant woman who's dominant in some
other way and this might be driving the
coordination right so here there was no
direct link between these women other
than body orders so if the effect
re-emerged
um it would definitely be an olfactory
effect and what she found is that if she
took a sweat from the follicular or the
ovulatory phase of the donors one
extended the cycle in recipients and one
shortened the cycle in recipients I
don't remember which was which but but
basically uh uh definitely denoting uh a
chemo signaling effect uh with with the
opposing uh effects on duration based on
the time it was collected from
again published in nature in 1998.
that's it I I there's a quotation I
think this is from from
uh
I'm not sure but but you know that that
uh uh if something is published in
nature or science that doesn't
necessarily mean it's not true so uh
with that in mind
um
the findings were since called into
question quite widely
um
one reason is just
statistics of cyclic events are
surprisingly complicated
so so It's Tricky it's once you have a
cyclic event statistics become tricky
and and so
Martha took a lot of heat on the
statistics of of claiming an effect
and I think there was at least one
effort
of replication that didn't really work
out
um if you ask me I'm on the fence
so I I'm and but I'm maybe in a minority
in my field I think a majority in the
field uh is currently negative I'm not
um and I've we've said in lab that we
should do a planned replication
um we will it's just
again it's a horrible study to run it's
tons of work and you and and you have to
run it for a really long time
uh and and uh so it's just completely
non-trivial
um but we have a graduate student now
and lab interested in these exact things
uh Road wisegross and she's doing
similar stuff and and I hope we'll we'll
do that I hope we'll try to to replicate
this
um very interesting result and I think
uh interesting because it of its Real
World
um meaning outside the laboratory of
course our experiment analog but also
because
pheromone effects and olfactory effects
in humans seem unique among uh
neurobiological slash endocrine
phenomena because there seems to be so
many stories that we all have of the
smell of our grandmother's hands or the
recognizing the scent of of somebody or
I knew from the moment that
um I smelled their breath or you know or
I just liked their smell kind of thing
these kind of things that that inform
the the Deep potential for a real
biological phenomenon as opposed to the
kind of thing like oh uh you know you
just throw something out there oxytocin
is bonding and all of a sudden you know
the the general public not at no to no
fault of their own comes to think that
every every aspect of bonding is is
oxytocin and every defect in bonding is
lack of oxytocin but
the the general public provides a sort
of a rich
um it's fodder for for exploring all
these things and a lot of times they
turn out to be true right when in the
context of old action yeah no it's it's
a very Primal system you know so so uh
it's it's linked to the most
you know limbic Primal mechanisms in our
brain and it drives Primal Behavior it's
an incredible system I I have a question
about
a particular study but I'm just going to
cue it up and you'll know immediately
what I'm I'm queuing up
um and that is what is the relationship
between odors and hormones and in
particular
crying as I pointed out previously the
the sort of flavor of the month in in
human social chemo signaling research is
the smell of fear and the the media of
the month is Sweat Right so so
um the the few maybe tens of labs in the
world that study uh Human Social chemo
signaling all collect sweat and and
that's the media uh they look at is it
always from the armpit org is there are
there meaningful differences in terms of
the sweat emitted from different
locations on the body I already know the
answer to that as I ask it but let's
just stay above the waistline and um oh
no no yes or below the waistline I mean
we're biologists after all we we just
yeah so it's it's funny we we have we're
working on a paper on that right now on
the smell of fear uh so so we have a
nice Paradigm for uh generating fear we
throw people out of airplanes it's a
very effective way to generate fear to
come to your lab it sounds like the
greatest lab in the world we didn't
invent that by the way uh the first to
do that was uh um and I hope I'm
pronouncing her name correctly I think
it's mujika perudi
um but but um that's our Paradigm for
generating fear and we started that on
our own but uh We've since entered into
collaboration with the Israeli
paratroopers Brigade and we now collect
body odor from every First Time Jumper
so
um we we went that path because
we like everybody else in this field you
know the Holy Grail there is is finding
the molecules right I mean if you'll
have the fear molecules
that's a bonanza right because I mean
you know you could think of many reasons
why it would be a bonanza but for for me
you know if you find the molecules you
can then try and find The receptors and
when you find the cognitive receptors
you can then develop blockers and you
can imagine you know uh um uh um
what's the term I'm looking for um
I'm switching into Hebrew it's about
midnight now right I'm sorry you're
doing incredibly well considering two in
the morning yeah we would never know
um no one traveled in today from Israel
so he's a circadian inverted as we say
uh
um anxiety so so uh you can imagine
developing like a nasal spray against
anxiety right where where you would
quell those receptors and kill the fear
response right which rather than going
the current path which is through
neurotransmitters that then have effects
all over the place you would be getting
fear at its source right so so that
would be why I would want that and and
we figure out that doing that
you know collecting fear from like three
four or five people
um in an experiment you'll never be able
to do analytical chemistry on that so we
now have uh we have uh a setting we call
fear Bank uh which now has more than a
thousand samples in it so we're trying
to do uh uh analytics on that but
in doing that we've we've joined you
know the the crowd everybody's doing
fear and everybody's doing sweat and in
one of our discussions in the lab you
know we're saying well there's got to be
you know or there potentially definitely
could be additional bodily media
that are are playing into social chemo
signaling
uh now many of these you know you can't
really study right I mean so you know
just to throw what most terrestrial
mammals communicate social information
through urine
um but you know starting doing
experiments with humans with smelling
urine it would be difficult you know
both in IRB and in agreement and
you know and and then we we you know
this is a rare case where we actually
hypothesize what we set out to do and
you know and then only claim in
retrospect that it was hypothesis
um is is tears
[Music]
um
we we started thinking about tears and
looking into tears because tears are a
bodily liquid emotional tears that that
we emit in emotional situations where
where these are situations where
nonverbal communication is is critical
and key
and and tears are a liquid that that
is puzzling Beyond ocular maintenance
right and so so you know the the most
influential text I think till this day
in in Emotion research is is Darwin's
book uh uh the showing of the emotions
in men and animals I think is the full
name of the book
and an entire chapter chapter six is
devoted to tears
an entire chapter of this book why with
no conclusion why because the book
revolves around
describing the functional antecedence of
emotional Expressions so for example uh
showing of the teeth is a sign of
aggression right so so animals first bit
with their teeth and and Darwin argued
that through Evolution uh just uh
showing the teeth alone became an
aggressive sign because it started from
biting
or what I I find is a beautiful example
and this is work partly done by by Adam
Anderson now at Cornell
um is is the uh emotional expression of
disgust
so disgust which comes from Line This
goosia distaste right is spitting
something out of your mouth now what
what Adam showed is is that the
musculature patterns of activation and
the temporal sequence of activation
when you experience moral disgust are
the same as when you spit a bitters
taste out of your mouth right so again
so there's a functional antecedent
spitting something out and through
Evolution the argument was that it
became an expression of emotion and you
express disgust just as if you're
spitting something out of your mouth
even though they're you know in the case
of moral disgust there's nothing you're
spinning out of your mouth so so darn
systematically went through the
expressions of emotions and for each one
went to their functional antecedent and
explained everything very nicely and
then he got stuck with tears right
because tears are an obviously emotional
expression and he could not find
a functional uh antecedent so he ended
up saying this is an epic phenomenon
basically right I I don't know what all
scientists do when they don't have a
good explanation you know blame it on
nature right right so so
and but he bothered to write this entire
chapter on on the ocular or sort of
Maintenance you know function of tears
and so on so forth but but nothing
emotional so we thought well maybe the
function is is a chemical signal
and
and you know so so with that in mind we
we harvested emotional tears uh which
was also an amusing event on its own
right because we we uh we uh
we we posted
um messages
on all sorts of boards that that uh
we're seeking
um
experiment participants who cry with
ease
now this generated an unfortunate gender
bias in our study right because we
received about 100 women volunteers and
about one man
and you know I think this is not a
problem only in in Macho Israel right
probably anywhere in the west this would
be I mean definitely in America would be
the same I think my guess is that there
are probably men out there who cry
easily emotional tears because I'm sure
that they're just going to show up yeah
that's what I'm saying it's a cultural
thing it's not you know you're not going
to come to a lab and say yeah you know I
cry all the time it's just not going to
happen
oh
and then um we we what we did is uh for
each one of these participants you know
we would ask them you know is there a
particular film event that you know of
that you know a scene that that makes
you cry and and interestingly in these
effective choirs there's always oh yes
you know the scene in in so and so I
always cry profusely from that you know
they they have to give me an example of
one of the more commonly used scenes
yeah with these
um
the movie The Champ
the champ dies he's a boxer and he dies
and literally in the hands of his about
eight-year-old son
and his son is standing next to his bed
and you know saying chap Chap and and he
dies right
it's a winner okay
waterfall yeah yeah got it so you know
we're probably the neurobiology lab with
most sad movie films on those shelf in
the world right we have a whole huge
collection there is the same thing as
Tears of Joy by the way so no no well
we're going ahead of ourselves but they
say we tried to collect them and failed
um even people who think they shed tears
of joy and laughter their eyes water a
bit but it's not the same thing
in in in the effective choirs we end up
screening so I can write we collect a
full mL of Tears a full mL of Tears in
about 15 minutes wow so so that's
pouring right and that doesn't happen
from laughter that we or we've never
seen that we've never seen that happen
from a lot but we tried
um so so um
so we have we have all these sad films
and by the way one of the amusing things
is uh when we ultimately published this
paper in in science
um we were forced in retrospect to go
out and actually buy the films right I
mean you know originally we like
downloaded the rear there but you can't
because you're you'd be violating uh uh
you know uh copyright laws right so we
had to buy like purchase all these films
that the parts and watch them so we we
actually have these in lab like DVDs you
know that we actually purchased
um but so nice coverage of a potential
legal Fallout that I've known no we did
yeah
so uh and yeah and and well we can touch
on that later but up
so um
so most of these uh volunteers who who
come saying they can cry with ease
actually don't meet the bill
um and so out of the about 100 at least
more women that we screened we ended up
uh with about six
who who could really come to lab week
after week
and and poor tiers there's a name for
this in Psychiatry they call it um a
narrative distancing some people when
they watch a film where someone's
getting hit they they they they Flinch
quite a lot they it's almost as if
they're experiencing it it but it works
in the opposite direction too I know
someone like this um where if they watch
a film that someone's experiencing
something even mildly positive that
their mood elevates so they they can
quickly Bridge yeah um and it's not
always adaptive as you can imagine so
there's a lack of narrative distancing
right yeah what one you know issue you
can bring up with this entire line of
studies in our lab is is I don't know if
there's something very unique about the
donors right I mean we're assuming these
are tiers and this is pretty common I
think that the numbers I saw out there
about five to eight percent that's
exactly what we got about right
so so we collected um
um tears
and and we exposed uh participants uh to
these tiers
and and we found a few things first of
all the tears are completely odorless
you cannot detect them at all completely
odorless
um
And yet when you sniff them you have a
pronounced uh reduction in testosterone
uh within about 20 minutes half an hour
this is men and women smelling in
women's tears just men swelling women's
tears but not perceiving any odor
nothing just sniffing them
and you have uh about uh 14 drop in free
testosterone free okay so this is
testosterone that's already been
liberated from the testes free testers
we've done a few hormone that's uh
either bound or Unbound is Unbound
excuse me
um from sex hormone and globulin Etc and
it's the active form so it's it's uh
it's subject to very short time scale
changes yeah and and this is you know
people who who study testosterone which
is not me but they tell me this is a
really strong effect like it's it's hard
to even pharmacologically get an effect
like that that fast I mean no in
Pharmacology yeah years ago I spent time
studying endocrine effects of this sort
um and that's a tremendous resized
effect so and so here I'll point out in
passing uh that uh one of the concerns
we had because of the uh
effort to run this study is that nobody
would ever try to replicate it and to
our Joy about two years later an
independent group from uh uh South Korea
uh oh it Al who I don't know at all uh
replicated the testosterone effect to a
t i mean like same numbers
so so
um it it lowers testosterone and and
we then also looked uh using Mr at the
at the uh
um effect
on brain activity and saw pronounced uh
if effect on activity a dampening a
lowering of activity uh under under uh
an arousing State a lowering of activity
um both in the hypothalamus
um and in the fusiform gyrus for
whatever reason I don't know recognition
area amongst other things yes
um and we don't know why
um but pronounced
um and currently
um Shania gron in our lab is replicating
this again and this time with a stronger
behavioral component
um and I can share with you uh
unpublished uh data now under review
um that's as you would expect given the
effect on testosterone perhaps uh
sniffing tears lowers aggression in men
uh using again the tap the same
experiment used by evine in the uh
hexadecanal experiment that's happening
I'm going to think of that as the the
say to the title The titration the
sadist hydration yeah Tyler aggression
Paradigm so not unlike the Milgram
experiments of the of the 1950s which
post
um this is looking at sort of uh post
Holocaust Behavior you know people
basically in American Laboratories
thinking they were torturing other
people yeah simply because they were
told to and a lot of people did that
even though most people would report
that they would never torture someone
yeah no humans are not a wonderful
species
I think it was the the great Carl Jung
that said um we have all things inside
of us but um the goal is not to
experience them all certainly
um it's an incredible study and it
points again to the the power of of um
these chemo sensory systems and Pathways
and uh obviously there's so much here
um I don't know if you want me to to
tell about this or not and I guess you
can edit it out at least you don't but
uh please this is just you know sharing
stories about the politics of Science
and and
so whereas the effect on testosterone
was was uh replicated by by an
independent group
um
in the original study in in science
where we had we it had three components
one was the effect on testosterone which
was robust the second which was brain
activity which was robust
and there was a significant but weaker
effect on behavior and I don't think we
studied the right behavior in retrospect
what we looked at then was uh readings
of arousal associated with pictures
and there was an effect it was
significant but it was it was not what
carried the story
um now there's a lab in Holland
um of a guy by the name of
I'm probably mispronouncing this but I
think it's vingerhots
for the non-dutch yeah Dutch names are
always a little bit of a challenge but
and I shouldn't say that being an
Israeli I shouldn't go too much on that
line but but uh that lab
really didn't like our original tear
story
and the reason they didn't like it is
because they've they've built a career
on this notion
um including a book with this title that
emotional cheers are uniquely human
now
here I should well I should share so one
of the things we really liked about that
the the uh tier result is that
partially before we did our work but
more afterwards and and we like that
because usually things so usually in our
chemo signaling work like what I told
you before about the Bruce effect we
look at what happens in Ruins and we see
if the same thing is happening in humans
this was a rare case where after we did
this work
um
more or less identical effects were
discovered in rodents so uh a paper
published in nature two years later
found that Mouse tears uh Mouse pup
tears lower aggression in in male adult
mice towards them in a in a smell
dependent way yeah yeah so and and they
also actually found the actual component
in tears that so the tier pheromone that
lowers aggression right so so you know
this has us thinking of regret as tears
is as you can think of Tears as like a
chemical blanket in a way that that
you're covering yourself up again with
you know to protect against aggression
right and
and so our finding you know which to me
I mean this is consistent with how I
think about behavior in general you know
I don't think you know beyond language
there are very few things definitely
sensory things that are uniquely human
you know I I I'd be hard-pressed but so
so you know our finding when it gets you
know against their their story right
because you know here we're saying no
you know tears are this schema signaling
mechanism like all animals and by the
way I you know just after this entire
debate about uh um six months ago there
was a paper in current biology the dogs
emit emotional tears and and it was uh
the dogs emit emotional Interiors when
they reunite with their owners and you
were talking before about about um
oxytocin so I think what they showed
there is that not only that but that the
the the view as seeing the tears and the
dog influences oxytocin and in the
humans hope I'm getting this right now I
absolutely believe this I mean I from
the from the time I brought Costello
home at eight weeks old guys tell us
your dog is my dog unfortunately a long
time actually the only time I can recall
crying
listen I've certainly cried before many
times in my life
um many many times
[Music]
um
the only time I ever recall crying to
the point where I wasn't sure that I
could keep producing two years but
somehow it is when I had to put him down
right it's just like you know and if I
talk about too long ago you know it's
one of those things yeah I think it's a
healthy yeah emotional state for sure
but I recall when he was a puppy
thinking this oxytocin thing must be
real because
I can recall being in faculty meetings
which you know very fairly stated are
not always that interesting but they
could be pretty interesting and someone
presenting data in my mind
thinking I hope Costello's okay what's
he doing down in my office is when he
was very little and also not needing to
eat
not being able to focus on anything else
except my attachment to him for about
the first two or three weeks that I had
him then it was easy then I could focus
off on other things and I think I think
that dogs
perhaps through oxytocin hijack the
circuitry that's intended for child rear
yeah I really do otherwise why would
people be so ridiculously attached to
their dogs I mean hence all the the
posts of everyone thinks their dog is
the cutest dog the same way everyone
thinks their children are the cutest
children you know by the way
too so so yeah so so again so they're so
even you know to put another nail in
that story of of uh of tears are
uniquely human so they're not dogs shed
emotional tears
um and and and so that really didn't
like this and they went ahead and and
tried to replicate and to your listeners
I'm showing double uh quotations on the
replicate uh only the behavioral part
the ratings of arousal
um uh in women
of women uh and and failed to replicate
that I see now this was you know just
sharing on how science works and it
doesn't work in my in my notion in this
case
so at the time
um
after they got this accepted in some
Journal
[Music]
um
not a field journal in the Journal of
memory of something
um
they contacted me for a response
and I I wrote to the office and I said
look you know uh this is very odd to me
why don't you come you know why don't we
replicate this again together and see if
it doesn't work if it doesn't work I'll
publish it with you that it doesn't work
but you know
um and so I said why don't you send over
a graduate student or the lead author
and we'll do it here and we'll show them
how it's done because they they did it
very wrongly in the paper
um and so they replied that uh no they
don't have money to send over uh
graduation to do it so I replied saying
okay I'll fund the graduate student
coming over and I'll fund the entire
study in their stay and so on and so
forth then let's do this together and
they replied no they're not willing to
to do that
which you know I don't think is the way
things should work
um and and they published this sort of
failed uh uh behavioral effect in in
that paper
um so I'm just sharing this you know
that it's not only there was that
successful replication with the effect
on testosterone but there was supposedly
this fail replication on the effect in
in Behavior
um and then I published a rebuttal on on
that which I don't know if I should have
done but I did well I think it's it's
interesting I mean I I think um provided
studies are done correctly I mean the
positive result
um almost always trumps the negative
result and yet I think replication is
key the problem as you point out is that
replication is rarely pure replication
of these yeah this one's not even
remotely but in I I published the detail
so actually they hid something in their
data that did partially rip so I asked
for their data and I re-analyzed it and
that's what I published in the rebuttal
but you know this is just sharing on how
science works I I took advice so I'm
it's not that that I'm friends with him
but at that time I was communicating a
bit because we're on some board with
with uh with uh Daniel conman who's
who's Nobel looking fast and slow right
and so so uh I asked him how how should
I deal with this
you know give me some advice here I was
really you know it it was an emotionally
not fun to be in that position and he
said don't don't
never publish a rebuttal don't do
anything
as you know how can I you know I have to
do something he said no don't because
once you do that then you know people
don't go into the details they won't
read the details of your about all
they'll be like well there's a group
that says this and there's a group that
says that so it's unclear well and yeah
I mean I I appreciate that you're
bringing it up today and I I do
appreciate that you published the
rebuttal and that you offered in a very
magnificent way to do a collection
that's what he then said that's so so
Common's advice after that was that well
if you insist then just publish Write a
response that you offered them to to
come do it together they refused and
there's nothing you can do about that
it's a lot like
um fight sports right people talk a lot
of trash although in science you know I
will say this you know as long as we're
on the the sociology of science
science is very different than
podcasting or social media or other
fields because in science people
generally are very kind to your face and
then they you get it in the you get it
in the neck on Grant reviews or
Anonymous reviews
um I was on a grants review panel this
morning I'm a nice reviewer meaning I
judge things objectively but I I try to
always
um think from the perspective of the
graduate student or author of the of the
proposal listen I I think that um
science is a is a game of of people who
most of them are seeking facts however
the the ego is strongly woven into it
like any like anything else so I think
it was uh very magnanimous of you to
offer the collaboration so I'm going to
tell this lab whose name I can't
pronounce
um please accept the collaboration then
we can invite everyone on here for a
round table
um I appreciate that you shared that
story and I know a number of other
people will
um for a number of reasons I have a
couple of more questions
um and I realize and thank you by the
way for your uh for your willingness and
stamina because it is probably 1am
Israel time now
um and you just arrived later I think um
but you're doing uh terrifically well so
I I
um if you'll indulge us just a touch
further there are two topics that
um I want to touch on and if you want to
cover these in shorter Thrift that's
fine although don't feel any obligation
to
um the first one is
I think most people are familiar with
the scent of food or Foods as a signal
of the nutrient contents of those Foods
um you know an orange that smells great
or the smell of something baking you
know it didn't it it suggests something
about the the contents and quality of
that food after all you and I both
separately lived in the same apartment
in Berkeley above the cheeseboard which
the smell is wafting up through the
cheeseboard is something I will never
forget and the breads never forget it
um amazing uh I mean I don't know if
you've conveyed that clearly enough to
listeners or Watchers now the
probability really just discovered that
we lived in the same we've never met I
mean like this before yep and we lived
in the same room exactly where we click
friends
in a lingering way I guess absolutely
through the uh through the floorboards
it had a great floor of that place it
had a great wooden floor it was an
amazing place I lived there with my
girlfriend for a year and a half and
then uh it was an amazing place
um we won't give it out the address for
out of respect for the people that live
there now
um but do check out the cheese board if
you ever in Berkeley their hours are
weird but so you have to look online but
that they're it's a unique Place yeah
with great bread and cheese and um some
good flavors of pizza
um in any case
um I'm wondering whether or not smell
can signal things about the nutrient
contents of foods in a way that's
divorced from the smell that we are
perceiving so for instance I could
imagine based on what you've told us
about smell today that
um you know I
I don't know I I I smell a a piece of
meat cooking and it smells great to me
and I think of it as oh that's so Savory
and my mouth is watering and I love the
smell of this and I'm thinking okay this
is protein and fat and I love the taste
of steak and a little bit of char but
that nature has co-opted that
to
get ensure or I should say increase the
likelihood that I will ingest some other
thing that's in stake for that has no
odor but whose nutrient content is very
important to me for instance amino acids
right right I mean amino acids are
essential to life and yet um we don't go
around sniffing for amino acids we go
around sniffing for savoriness Umami
type uh us tastes and things of that
sort so um I could imagine a million
different examples of this in the same
way I could imagine that the scent of
somebody that we fall in love with or
become romantically attached to or you
know sexually attracted to is signaling
all sorts of things about sure the
potential for offspring of a particular
immune status that's a long term game
but also
um something about
um
pleasure and safety of a potential
interaction so what I'm asking here is
about that whether or not there are
subconscious signals that the um
olfactory system has learned to seek but
learn to seek through more overt signals
sort of the tip of the iceberg
phenomenon so you know I don't have a
good answer for you although I think
it's a really good question
um or or a good idea in fact so so
whether
the there's you know order cues on
nutrient value
is a really good idea moreover it's
probably good to the extent that
somebody probably did it and I should
know and don't
um we haven't done anything on that line
so I don't know I don't know if if the
nutrient value of food is systematically
encoded in order
um if that's not been done and I will
check after our uh meeting today then it
should be
um it's a really good idea I mean one of
the reasons I asked this is because um
you know the Obesity crisis in the U.S
is a huge issue and elsewhere and highly
processed foods
um you know I have a lot of things that
are problematic but one of the things
that they don't have uh often is a
direct relationship between the scent
The Taste and the new and the nutrient
content and I don't mean macronutrient
sugar fat excuse me carbohydrates fats
and proteins but the the vitamins and
micronutrients things that support the
microbiome whereas foods that are not
highly processed
for instance meat or a piece of fruit
um contain many micronutrients that are
vital to aspects of our biology but we
don't go around sniffing for probiotics
I'll tell you one sort of factoid that
may support your hypothesis here
and that is that
there appears to be potential olfactory
perceptual similarity
in metabolic products
so something that's metabolized from
something else
has perceptual similarity across those
those two things so so so metabolic
Cascades play into the coding of
olfactory space
and and that is consistent with the
direction your your implying but again I
don't I don't know of a direct test of
of
nutritional value in smell and and
again the fact that I don't know it
doesn't mean of course that it doesn't
exist and in this case I would suspect
that it should exist
um in scientific press and and if not
there then with
the companies that have vested interest
in this which are many
um uh briefly sure just just an amusing
anecdote to share with you is that we've
received
too independent
um
people you know companies who have
turned to our lab recently uh asking for
help uh to to bring odor to engineered
meat right that's a growing thing and
all these you know meats that are
annoying you had to bring it up this
this audience is going to be very
polarized along the along the lines of
engineered meat um you're not you're not
from you're not promoting oh no no no no
no no I am I'm agnostic but but uh but
we've had two companies turn to us and
say look you know we have this great
product but it just doesn't smell like
meat so help us make it smell like meat
interesting uh the reason it's so
polarizing is that anything related to
nutrition on social media is a total
barbed wire topic we've had experts on
nutrition come on here we'll have more
but I I have nothing you're safe no
don't worry no it's not and it's not
promoting uh this he hasn't even said
whether or not he's going to help them
out no um we're not actually no no
because yeah I just never it didn't
happen no yeah no the the whether or not
those um engineered meats are uh yum
yuck or met is is a personal issue to
people in terms of taste whether or not
they are better for neutral or worse for
you and the planet than given the
ingredients that are required that's a
whole world we'll avoid now I will but
you know I'll take that the opportunity
to to highlight something related maybe
because I'm on what were you saying on
the
on the scale
you know there's this
you know I'll take the opportunity to
dispel another misconception about
olfaction
right there's this common notion that
our sense of smell
um is incredibly subjective
right and that what you might like in a
smell I will not liken the smell and
that we all have our own you know
totally subjective world of all faction
I think I know the study you're going to
tell me there are many the
cross-cultural similarities there are
many that that is utterly untrue many
not only from my lab there are many from
many Labs uh please clarify for those
that don't follow this list so
um yeah so so
humans
are incredibly similar to one another
and they're olfactory perception and
this is in contrast to what most people
think so why why is there this
misconception
the misconception is there for two
reasons first of all or for several
reasons but two are stand out
first of all we're attracted by outliers
because you know what I'll tell somebody
look you know for example a factory
pleasantness is highly correlated
amongst humans and let's first put this
in numbers you'll take a a bunch of
humans and a bunch of odorants and have
them write pleasantness the correlation
across uh the humans will be about 0.8
that's incredibly High incredibly High
what do you think is Pleasant I think is
yeah yeah now why why is that go against
what culturally people think
for two reasons first of all
where we're attracted or biased by
outliers but that's particularly that
shows in fact the results what do I mean
so you'll tell somebody look people are
very similar in their pleasantness
estimates and that's all you know that
can't be I love cilantro and you know my
girlfriend hates the smell of cilantro
right or and there are a few classic
examples there right you know is another
uh uh polarizing order so there are a
few polarizing orders right and and
that's true right so that's true that
you know half of the population loves
the smell of cilantro and half hates it
half loves guiava half hates it that's
microwave popcorn
however
I assure you that you know you can come
to our lab we have about a thousand
odorants in our lab okay we won't smell
the Thousand right but I assure you you
know take a hundred odorants okay from
our mixtures and Labs right and we'll
we'll smell them right and
out of the hundred orders
90 will totally agree on right and
including Universe I mean you know
nobody will say they like the smell of
feces or fecal smells and everybody will
say they like the smell of rose and
Flowery smells there will be rare rare
exceptions again the correlation is
about 0.8 across individuals
so on 90 of 100 will really be in high
agreement then five orderings will be in
sort of intermediate agreements and yes
they'll be the five orderings that were
in total disagreement on but I asked you
you know if we agree on 95 and disagree
on five are we the same or are we
different we're the same they're just
outliers to this to this Rule and and
and so one reason is this issue of of
outliers attract how we think about
things but no we're actually much more
similar than than what we think
and the second thing that that drives
this cultural effect is the LA is our
poor application of language to
olfaction right so so in other sensory
systems we grow up with we're we're we
develop with anchors right so since
you're a little kid you know your mother
shows you a cow and says what does a cow
do moo right and we all know moo moo and
what color is this it's well this is
kind of an odd black but it's black
right or what color is that it's red
right so you have these anchors but as
you all know you know the red that I'm
seeing is not necessarily the red that
you're seeing we just both know to call
that red and since you say red and I say
red I think why we're seeing the same
thing but no we're not seeing the same
thing right and in odor we don't have
those anchors right we we don't from
childhood you know our mom doesn't tell
us so what's this smell and what's that
smell right and so we don't have these
language anchors that make us think that
we're perceiving the same thing now how
can you quantify that
the most important term in in measuring
sensory systems is similarity right
that's the measure right so what can you
let's say we take 10 odorants and I have
you rate all the pairwise similarities
right so you'd end up with 45 numbers
right so you know how similar is one to
two one to three and one to four and
then two and all the possible pairwise
similarities let's say you rate
similarity from one which is totally
dissimilar to 100 exactly the same right
so now I have a similarity Matrix
that describes Andrew's perception of
smell right I have you know based on
these 10 odorants that I selected now I
can run my similarity Matrix and then I
can see if the similarity Matrix are
correlated right and then we've gotten
rid of the issue of names and orders
right it doesn't matter if I'll call
this lemon in this orange and you call
this sweet potato in this marshmallow
right it doesn't matter if I think that
these two are highly similar and you
agree and I think that these two are
very different and you agree right we
perceive the world in the same way if
our similarity matrices are aligned
right and what's nice about that is that
then you can do that for vision audition
and off action in a common group and you
can see where we're more alike each
other or not and we've done that for
color vision all faction internal
audition okay and we are most dissimilar
in color vision
okay where in color vision the variance
is about 100 amazing it's quite
different and there's tons of literature
on this tons of it tons of it right and
in all faction and audition they're
about the same
so we're not different we're very
similar we're just very poor at
appreciating this
and and mind you not that there's not
variability there is variability and of
course the system is malleable as all
sensory systems are so you can learn to
like an order and and that will change
you and learn to dislike in order right
but just the way you can learn to like a
sound or dislike a sound so you know
this doesn't take away from the
hardwired link of a structure to its
perception that you can that they're
malleable and and and we're we're not
very variable we're we're actually kind
of similar
that's a perfect segue to the question I
have next which is if
in general people perceive certain odors
similarly
you could imagine that odors could be
um manufactured co-opted uh Etc in order
to elicit richer sensory experiences and
drive Choice making
um that's obvious at the level of the
smell of a hot dog stand or freshly
baked bread Etc but what I'm talking
about here and I'd like to ask you about
is doing this at scale and scientists
Geeks like to say in silico in uh
through computers so for a long time now
there's been this idea that there will
soon be Google smell not to call out
Google is the only search engine but
Duck Duck Go smell for those of you that
don't want to hear smell chat chat and
on and on in other words
you know Vision visual key information
is sent through uh computer interfaces
as is auditory information not so much
haptic somatosensory although it can you
know we our lab uses VR it's it it can
be done right um but it hasn't really
taken hold
um however smell being such a rich
source of
behavioral and hormonal and other sorts
of deep deep information that can drive
people in to Yum yuck or meh type
decision making yeah uh seems like an
amazing candidate so what is your
experience with
um generating smells in silico in
computers and here folks for those of
you that aren't catching on to this and
and I don't expect that everyone would
because what we're really alluding to
here
um is the idea that you'll look at
you'll put into a search engine
um uh blueberry pancakes recipe
and that not only will you get photos of
those blueberry pancakes and a recipe
but you will get the hopefully validated
odor of those pancakes and that recipe
coming at you in real time through the
computer
so I'll start off answering from uh from
the uh the name you threw out there
Google
so about probably about five years ago
uh
Google had an April Fool's spoof oh
right and they put out this video
of Google smell okay and and it had all
these like classic like sales images of
you know holding up your phone to a rose
and it generating rows and and and all
these things right
so Google is now trying to do that
um and they just they just uh uh
published I mean I I know they've been
trying to do it for a while they visited
our lab uh but they just sort of went
public with this that really just like
about a month ago or something that that
um they have this offshoot startup
um I think it's called osmo or something
like that that
started off with a ridiculous sum of
money for a startup like yeah I don't
know tons of money a lot there's a lot
of money in that world yeah yeah in
Google yeah
um
to to um you know to digitize uh smell
and and um
and there are other companies that are
trying to do this as well
um and we've been talking now for quite
a while about our our Labs chemo
signaling work but actually half of our
lab is devoted to this question of of uh
ultimately digitizing smell
um
and and so so this is a very very active
field of research and and and I'll say
um
one thing that that dovetails with what
you were talking about before
um in many ways
covid is going to be one of the best
things that ever happened to all faction
research
because suddenly all the world
um is all the world lots of people are
are um very cognizant of the importance
of smell and smells like way up there in
people's awareness because of covet and
this is driving a Renaissance of of
olfaction research and
in Awareness to all faction is something
that's worth paying attention to uh
and and our lab has been involved in
this way in this effort for a long time
where where the initial part of this
effort
is in fact to develop a set of rules
that link order structure to odor
perception
that is
the going thing was that that until
recently at least there was no scientist
or perfumer for that matter who could
look at the structure of a novel
molecular mixture and predict for you
how it will smell
or smell something and tell you what
molecular structure could or should be
you know so in contrast let's say the
trivial like color vision let's say so
you know if you know what the wavelength
of the light is you more or less know
what perceived color it's going to be of
course there are exceptions to that and
and all sorts of issues but as a rule
you you would know or you know or the
other way around you know you can
generate a wavelength and you would know
what color light uh it's going to be
perceived
um so so that's an example of where the
rules linking structure in this case
measured by wavelength and perception in
this case experience this color the
rules are well known in olfaction we
didn't have that until recently
um but over the past two years a bunch
of labs have really
um uh pushed this forward uh there's a
bunch of work out of Leslie vosh Hall's
Lab at Rockefeller and Andreas Keller
working with Leslie
um uh who've done a lot of work on this
front
um also work from Joel mainland's Lab at
monell
um and fair Discovery Joel was a
graduate student in our lab
um and and recently in our lab we've had
it and I hope this doesn't come across
as overly arrogant but we we've had a
sort of mini breakthrough on this front
to call something a mini breakthrough is
far from arrogant and and this is a
paper uh led by Aaron ravia uh uh from
our lab and Kobe snitz also a major
contributor there a paper published in
nature uh about a year and a half ago in
the height of a coveted pandemic so
nobody really or I won't say nobody but
it wasn't noticed in the way it would
otherwise would have been it was it was
published in nature really on like a
week where the whole world was like
going berserk over covid
um
and in this paper we develop an
algorithmic framework uh where we can
predict the perceptual similarity
of any two molecular mixtures with very
very high accuracy
so if you give me two molecular mixtures
I can predict how similar you you will
smell them to be okay now not only could
we predict that but we could design it
so we can generate
um um
mixtures with known similarities
and the the result was highlighted and
you'll appreciate this coming from
vision is that using our algorithmic
solution we generated olfactory
metameres so we measured mixtures
completely non-overlapping in their
molecular structure but they smell
exactly the same
okay now if you would come to a classic
perfumer or most classic perfumers and
tell them that you can generate two
mixtures with zero molecules in common
but smell exactly the same
they would tell you no and yet we did
and anybody can recreate them this is
simple actually
um
in in the paper we do a few things like
we generate amid a mirror for uh Chanel
Number Five so you don't like perfume so
this one but but we we take so we
generate a Chanel Number Five with no
component from Chanel number five in it
okay
um and we actually have a publicly
available website I'll give it to you
for your links if you want that anybody
can do this we built an engine that you
can generate these these metameras now
once we did that
in a way we've generated the the the
infrastructure for digitizing smell
because
what again what we what are what our
algorithm predicts our framework
predicts is similarity but in a way
that's enough for you why is that enough
we have a map
of 4 000 molecules uh for each one we
know there are perceived smell
now you can make up any mixture you want
from me I can project it into that map
and measure its pairwise distance from
all the points in the map if it falls on
Lemon then what you generated smells
like lemon and if it falls you know on
tomato then what you generated smells
like tomato
so we we now solve that problem we can
predict the order of any molecular
mixture we can see how it's going to
smell
what we can do is then find a set of
components which we call outer primaries
that can be used to mix any odor that
you can perceive
and that's what we're working on now
um and in about a month ago so this is
in collaboration with a lab of Jonathan
Williams and Max Planck in Munich
Jonathan Williams is an uh atmospheric
chemist
uh but he's really good at at using gcms
these tools that measure molecules so
Jonathan Williams measured odorants in
Germany uh transmitted the information
to us over IP
uh we fed that into our algorithmic
framework and recreated it from a device
that mixes primaries
uh and we tried to do four different
odorants uh in our our proof of concept
test uh one of them uh was Rose and we
failed at recreating rows we in fact
recreated something that had a preset
but most people perceived it as bubble
gum
uh the second one we tried to do was a
nice and we failed at recreating Anis
and most people said it was Cherry which
is not very far but it failed
the third was gasoline
um and we were slightly but
significantly better than chance at
recreating Gasoline
um and the fourth was was violets and 15
of 16 peoples and violets so the first
order ever transmitted over IP is
violets and we did that last month
um of course
this is not anything near a practical
solution uh the device uh uh that
Jonathan was using to measure uh is uh
1.5 million dollar device bigger than
this table uh that's right I remember
when VCRs half the audience won't even
know what that is yours were like this
big so we're we're all good okay I'm all
good with the uh with the prediction
that things will come down in size and
cost yeah I'm just saying here you know
don't hold your breath for this to be on
your table tomorrow
um and and you know again even even you
know all we have in hand is this very
initial proof of concept you know it
doesn't it's not even yet close to being
a paper we are submitting because
there's still lots of work to be done uh
but we're on we're on the path uh we're
on the path and you know Google will
probably beat us to it uh they got a lot
no you seem pretty dogged in there yeah
but they have so much more resources
that uh that um at this stage it and
they've already published uh two papers
from that effort that are good uh yeah
you know they definitely have a lot of
dollars and a lot of people a lot of
good uh neuroscience and other biology
Engineering Graduate students and
postdocs go there but but um the real
question is are they getting the best
people because as you and I both know in
science the oftentimes it's small groups
of of the very best and most creative
people that can uh out run and outgun
large groups and and here I don't have
anything against Google either way yeah
um I I use it all the time I'm not a
betting man but I would put my my money
on Google on this race but I'll give
I'll try and give them a a run for their
money there you go that was well since I
mostly just want to see the problem
solved regardless of who gets there
first what I'll say is you better get
going Google because gnomes being he's
humble and he's dogged so I don't know
um better better get cracking there we
just cost the weekends of and uh and
broke up the relationships of a bunch of
scientists I remember when I was a
graduate student at Berkeley I remember
hearing there was a guy in in our common
friend uh or uh Irving zucker's lab that
worked hundred hours a week so I was
like oh I'll work 102 hours a week which
was not a good choice but in any case
it's it's uh it's abundantly clear that
you're making progress here and and I go
to some of the earlier discussions we
had and I think we're not just talking
about transferring recipes and smells of
food uh gasoline from people watching
the the F1 race or something but um I'm
thinking dating apps I'm thinking um you
nowadays everyone knows that when you
travel and you want to see your family
your grandkids or kids you better to get
on FaceTime and see them resume
um than to just hear their voice we're
also talking about being able to smell
them I'll tell you more than that I'll
tell you more than that I mean we're
talking now of trying to achieve uh the
olfactory equivalent of Circa 1956 black
and white TV okay basically right and
you know I'm not dreaming let's say of
being able to transmit to you the
difference between a Cabernet or
Amarillo right but if I can generate
something that's legally wine that will
be an amazing success from my
perspective right but Jump Ahead in your
imagination to to 4K order transmission
than medical Diagnostics is what you
want to be talking about because
in this is this is uh uh over uh
extension but
you can almost say that every disease
will have an odor I mean every disease
is a specific metabolic process
metabolic process have metabolites
metabolites have a smell
olfaction once it's digitized and and
high resolution which again in our hands
it's not going to be I mean we're
talking you know in my retirement maybe
I'll read about this one day if I'll
still have Vision I mean this is not
close but
when when olfaction digitization is
brought to the equivalent of 4K uh of
vision and audition that you have now
then it will be in medical diagnosis
you'll have excuse me for the uh the
imagery but you will have an electronic
nose in your bathroom uh each one of us
will have in the toilet and it will be
doing Diagnostics all the time and and
that's that's where it's going to go but
again not anywhere in the very close
future
well it's it's certainly an exciting
proposition and I'm delighted that you
and other groups um who are so strong
are working on it I really am
no my I want to say thank you for your
time today first of all uh this was a
tremendously interesting conversation I
mean we touched on so many things
hormone smells the architecture of the
olfactory system I know that people
listening to this are realizing but I'm
going to say it anyway uh what an
Incredible Gift you've given us in um as
a
expert in this field giving us this tour
of of the work that you and others uh
who you credit so generously
um have done to elucidate this
incredible system that we call olfaction
chemo sensation
also just for the incredibly pioneering
work that you've done you know I
I don't have many heroes in science I
have Heroes outside of Science and a few
insights but I'm gonna um I'm gonna uh
purposely embarrass myself a little bit
by saying that from the time I was at
Berkeley and I then and saw that
experiment being done and people
foraging uh falling Ascent trails and
then when I was a until I was a junior
Professor I used that in my teaching
slides
um in a class that I taught that was
sort of the early origins of this
podcast in many way and over and over
again when your laboratory publishes
papers I find like this is super
interesting super cool and I find myself
telling everybody about it and that's
really what I do for uh for a living is
I I learn and then I blab about it to to
the world so thank you so much for the
work that you've done in the spirit that
you bring to it whatever drives that
Spirit as the great late Ben Barris used
to say keep going because we are all
benefiting tremendously and
um and I also just want to say that you
know for people listening to this the
the spirit of science is one of as you
mentioned there's complex politics and
all these things but it's absolutely
clear that you Delight in the work you
do and um so I Delight in it I'm
grateful for it I'm grateful for your
time today and so on behalf of me and
and many many people listening to this I
just want to say send a huge debt of
gratitude thank you so much
so I'm I'm the I'm blushing I don't know
if this doesn't come across on the on
the radio Podcast but thank you so much
for very warm words I mean you know as
you know it when you work in your lab
you don't
there's these moments where you suddenly
discover that somebody is like
cares a bit about it and those are
always very rewarding moments because
usually you you function without that I
mean I guess that's one of the things
you need
to be a scientist is to have the
you know the drive to work without that
because it comes only rarely uh there's
immense gratitude and appreciation for
you and what you do from me and now I
know from uh a large segment of the
world as well so uh my only request is
that you come back and tell us about the
next results sometime not too long now
yeah well I'm going to catch you live
now although you have the power to edit
this so I guess that's not fair but
first you come visit us in Israel and
and tell us both about the science and
the public science work you're doing and
then I'll come again
a good bargain and again I accept
delighted thank you so much yeah
pleasure thank you for joining me for
today's discussion about olfaction and
chemo sensation with Dr Noam Sobel if
you'd like to learn more about the work
in the Sobel laboratory or read some of
the papers described during today's
episode as well as learn about the
current and future projects in the Sobel
laboratory please go to the link
provided in the show note caption if
you're learning from and or enjoying
this podcast please subscribe to our
YouTube channel that's a terrific zero
cost way to support us in addition
please subscribe to the podcast on both
Spotify and apple and on both Spotify
and apple you can leave us up to a five
star review if you have questions for me
or comments about the podcast or guests
or topics that you'd like me to include
in future huberman Lab podcast please
put those in the comment comment section
on YouTube I do read all the comments
please also check out the sponsors
mentioned at the beginning and
throughout today's episode that's the
best way to support this podcast not so
much on today's episode but on many
previous episodes of The huberman Lab
podcast we discuss supplements while
supplements aren't necessary for
everybody many people derive tremendous
benefit from them for things like
improving their sleep their focus and
hormone support the huberman Lab podcast
is proud to have partnered with
momentous supplements if you'd like to
see the supplements discussed on the
huberman Lab podcast please go to live
momentous spelled ous so that's
livemomentis.com huberman if you're not
already following the huberman Lab
podcast on social media we are huberman
lab on LinkedIn Facebook Twitter and
Instagram and on all those accounts I
include information some of which
overlaps with content of the uberman Lab
podcast but often which is distinct from
information covered on the huberman Lab
podcast so again it's huberman lab on
all social media platforms if you
haven't already subscribed to our
newsletter we have a zero cost monthly
newsletter it's called the neural
network new newsletter and it includes
podcast summaries and toolkits or
protocols for things like enhancing
sleep for exercise for meditation for
dopamine for focus and many other topics
to sign up you simply go to
hubermanlab.com go to the menu and click
on newsletter and provide your email and
I want to be clear that not only is the
neural network newsletter zero cost we
also do not share your email with
anybody once again I'd like to thank you
for joining me for today's discussion
about olfaction and chemo sensation with
Dr Noam Sobel and last but certainly not
least thank you for your interest in
science
[Music]